welcome back everybody it's 2024 and H3
podcast is back live after a long long
[Applause]
hius 3 weeks of a Shabbat a
resit you could say Shabbat a sabatical
is that related I feel like those words
have to be related I don't know the the
origin
ask your doctor yes so um wow there's so
much to talk to talk about so much has
happened the last time we were live was
during Our Extravaganza YouTube sexiest
night and it did live up it was so sexy
did live up the crowd was so sexy they
were
electric they were on
fire um but anyways thank you everyone
for being here I know it was a for some
of you it was a long break and uh it's
nice they say fondness makes the heart
grow or no this no hold on one sec yep
distance makes the heart grow
fonder like our story yeah right so
that's that's been us the last three
weeks but ah so what we sponsored by
today oh yes I'm a little rusty
stamps.com who I love God I love him
we're obsessed
yeah but let's see I mean there's so
much to talk about there's basically the
main thrust of this episode is going to
be over the weekend or over the
break this dude Jake Doolittle and I
I've been trying to think of the best
goof on his name there's so many options
right but here's this is what I settled
on Jake do better
oh got that's pretty good right because
of the do little yeah do better Jake do
do more more do more work do you not
like
Dr is pretty powerful it's it's obvious
Mega it's obvious sometimes the obvious
is just right well what's the story with
Dr doodle he could talk to animals right
mhm uh yeah cuz like it depends on who
is Dr
doo
doo it's a mega Doo let's see let me
read the synopsis and we can decide if
Dr ditt is good is it really this is it
just this movie no there's a yeah
there's a book okay the first one would
came out in the 60s with Jerry Lewis
yeah it was Jerry Lewis movie this is
like all that comes up for some reason
it's kind of funny here we go Dr dittle
has the world in his hands a beautiful
wife at his side two adorable daughters
and a career that could not be going
better but one night he nearly runs over
a dog with his car
keemstar well hit it yeah not nearly the
dog yells bone
head and disappears from then on his
child childhood ability is back to
communicate with animals so that's his
whole shtick so I don't know is that
good enough no cuz yeah that's kind of
dope Dr Do's dope he's like a good dude
MH well anyway this little punk put out
a
video right when we went on break which
you guys know how it
is and uh it's
probably all right listen I'm I'm going
to save it started but we're I'm going
to be responding to this video uh in
full if you guys will indulge me because
it's so
infuriating yep it is infuriating it's
like I tried watching it at home and 2
minutes in I had already paused it like
10 times to make notes because you felt
so called out and so seen so seen to
seen y we seriously could not um watch
it it's just we couldn't I'm so
angry too embarrassing for Ethan yeah I
agree I mean
it it's so
mean-spirited and it's so
nasty and for no reason like he takes a
he's taking shots that even keemstar
wouldn't even stoop as low as to no this
is a new level so I will be responding
to Mr do better that's good yeah it's
pretty good that's pretty thank you
thank you and uh we'll be getting into
that but I want to talk to everybody
first before we get into that so how's
everybody's break been nice to see you
guys missed you guys it was good it was
a good break it was yeah oh yeah
definitely it's a 3 weeks is a good
chunk of time yes indeed it's chunky
miss everybody yeah I did too I really
missed you guys like going home made me
really always makes me really realize
how much I appreciate you guys I love
you baby I miss you and L I especially
Miss Lena I miss Lena more than anybody
oh I miss you guys
too how was uh how was uh what's the
city called uh Dearborn how is Dearborn
uh it's it's Dearborn it feels like time
travel every time we go back it feels
like we're like 10 years in the past
every time we go that's how I feel when
I go back home yeah it's like traveling
back in time that yeah but Dearborn it's
got to be kind of a wild time there
right now with the war happening right
or is or is it not um well everyone's
kind of on the same page there so
there's that but also like I don't know
there's like this dude named uh hos
who is like waiting H cash local Legend
he's like waiting in the bushes at like
Starbucks's and then like if someone
drives through Starbucks because uh they
support Israel he'll like pop out with
his phone and like put you on his
Instagram oh yeah he's like uh yeah
so can I the the the Starbucks police I
don't understand the starbu Bucks
boycott I I've lived in Israel you guys
know there there's no Starbucks in
Israel this honestly the first I've
heard of this well I I've heard I don't
know what the reason is but there's a
whole list of like businesses you
boycott it just seems like on social
media I've seen that Starbucks
specifically being called out and I I'm
sure there was a reason I don't know I
like my coffee dark I think that's
that's pretty funny though that he's
yeah is's out there yall can't even get
Starbucks no it's completely on the oh
cuz who would want to be that yeah
hell no and like the people like I feel
bad the videos I did see are like old
ladies who probably are not I mean I
they have to know what's going on I
guess to a degree but they didn't get
the memo that someone's Wai they want
their Starbucks yeah but I guess it's
working because uh no one's there why is
Starbucks being
boycotted um Starbucks Workers United
counter sued Starbucks is because of the
Union stuff which
again has nothing to do with Israel
Starbucks Workers United counters suited
Starbucks asking federal court in
Pennsylvania to rule that it can
continue using it name and similar logos
and saying Starbucks defame the Union by
implying its Sports terrorism and
violence okay what did it
say all right maybe you can I'm Cur I'm
genuinely curious yeah I'm I'm looking
into it I've always heard that though
even prior to this conflict oh really
yeah that what that Starbucks is a huge
supporter of Israel really yeah like
even before this conflict like if I was
seen with the Starbucks cup I would see
comments here and there really Starbucks
Israel yeah because Zara have in Israel
so I yeah guess I can understand why
that one but yeah there there's zero
Starbucks in Israel like the
Jews um oh here's I guess here's the
statement they put
out I don't I can't I can't untangle
this why we why are we getting into this
let's let's have some fun today so well
yeah I mean we're not not having fun but
anyway uh welcome back thank you
yeah and death to Starbucks or wait can
I say that sure it's just a corporation
it's not a person I mean like bankrupt
them death to Starbucks
mhm no more lattes
people put them down no more whipped
cream uh anyone else how was everybody
else's love you were in Sweden right yep
it's very weird to go on vacation and go
home it's like I have two home shs ducky
what are you doing uh oh
yeah it's just weird you know he's just
destroying the carpet going from home to
go to Vacation back home I I don't know
it's a foreign concept to me cuz when I
was here before I went back home this
was vacation but now it's flipped it's
very weird was it nice very nice I
stayed for quite a long time and we just
you stay with your dad yep and my mom I
just stayed with both of them you how
many times did you eat Kebab Pizza like
a ridiculous amount really 50%
I probably okay realistically 35% of my
meals were Kebab related yeah you look
good I like the mustard oh thank you
yeah I just figured i' I think it
compliments your facial structure oh I
appreciate that thank you very much
we'll see if it stays did you lose
weight or something oh wow no probably
gained weight considering all theab yeah
the mustache I guess is working mustache
is okay I'll keep that in mind thank you
very much stashes are like kind of
having a moment aren't they big time
kind of
back it's 2010 all over again what you
been up to Dan uh I uh did some
traveling over the break visited family
I went up north and visited with alli's
family too and uh I know did did all
kinds of stuff I completely unplugged
from the H3 Universe until about 48
hours ago which was which was great um
uh not that I'm I'm glad to be back but
I just uh took a little mental vacation
as well as a physical one uh that's good
to reset yeah yeah I tried I think I did
pretty
good but I did get into a bit of Doom
scrolling on TW on Twitter but I'm I I'm
not on it that much it's just so
depressing every time I'm get off your
phone bro that's one thing I did over
this break is I I uninstalled the app
it's just gone the thing is so I did
that I tried that originally but I don't
know with work I felt like I got I need
a throwaway I need a throwaway account
so I can cuz Twitter's effed up like if
you get sent a link you can't even open
if you don't have the app let you see it
uh I don't know if that's true anymore
because I was you had sent some links
over the break and I it opens in the
browser on my phone it does that to me
sometimes because I don't have the app
anymore and sometimes stuff see it it
it'll show you the Tweet but you can't
look at like comments or see that's
probably for the best too yeah I still
don't have true and I will not install
it by the way I see YouTube is
completely up still was at 42,000 now
it's at 29,000 like hell yeah God we're
so back clearly they haven't been uh
getting a much there but they sent you
Crocs true they sent me some exclusive
Crocs oh it's over there you always say
YouTube never gives you anything they
they listen Dr
no
Crocs Zach no Crocs I said Crocs
I'm getting quite a collection of
rare Crocs going actually these are my
sneakers a little bit of a sneaker head
now man it's not that great though it's
like a notification Bell and like a
poorly printed on
YouTube I would not have approved that
if I saw the sample wait is it that
exclusive the play button is
backwards uh no when you put them in
sports mode which you're
supposed that's a major design FLA
why it flips It Forward when you're in
cash mode I wear it like this but I know
a lot of people wear it like never do
sports mode
yeah I love it love what sports are you
playing in those anything
life walking soccer football
rugby parachuting paragliding
Halo
Halo yeah and you were um alli's from
some uh good old Good Old State right
yeah she is she's from uh she's from the
great white north of Idaho which is um
pretty much I think it actually is the
reddest state in the country now even
more than oh uh some of the others that
might and and the area that she's from
in particular is like particularly
maggot out I saw so many Trump flags and
uh where people have like whole nativity
scenes of Maga on their
lawn yeah with like uh but that said it
is um it's very nice up there it's very
lovely as a city boy myself I I enjoy
the uh the fresh air and the the Wide
Open Country at least to visit I
wouldn't want to live there but the
people are were they um how were the
people they're nice to me I'm white yeah
and they don't know you're a lib yeah
they don't know me they don't know me
they could they could probably smell it
on me but they were probably just being
polite this WHYY from here yeah I tell
you what man we us here we read than our
necks actually um that you mentioned
that I wrote down their names because I
didn't want to forget uh I actually ran
into a couple who were Mega fans of the
podcast in fact they said that they
bonded and met uh or they bonded on
their first date on both being fans of
the a podcast Kendall and Megan and they
were getting married in just a few days
when I met met them congratulations
married we love love there's nothing
more that I love than love ducky is Just
Ducky isn't being I'm distracted because
I'm ducky is such a handful this dog
he's just from the minute he wakes up I
mean this is typical puppy behavior but
to the minute he goes to sleep he just
wants to play play play and poor Alfredo
he Alfredo's been doing really good with
him they've been playing a lot together
oh that's good yeah they've been getting
however the first thing in the morning
and when he's trying to sleep at night
he does not want to play and ducky does
this thing cuz Alfredo has like the
biggest ears massive floppy ears uh like
Dumbo sized and he'll bite his ears and
pull it he pulls them like like you
would if you were playing tug ofar with
him and the thing is that he bites us so
I know how painful it
is so it's a work in progress but he
getting actually is so well trained
already like great such a good dog step
with his the only Behavior issue besides
that
[Music]
is what oh let's start the year off with
a
button oh I didn't want that it didn't
hit okay but anyway Shredder yeah he
didn't he didn't eat a lot so ducky is
like the total opposite of him that but
like if I feed them together ducky he
eats his food so fast like he hasn't
eaten in a year ever and then he goes
runs immediately oh there he is hey
buddy you want you have something to say
there bud
duck chime
in oh he's so cute he's so cute and then
he'll beine straight to Alfredo's food
he doesn't he doesn't ask for permission
he doesn't hesitate he lunges for it
yeah like violently man it's crazy how
he's how he eats but anyway it's going
good with them that's
good
yeah
uh Olivia how was your your break my
break was good I went to New York and I
saw my friends
nice that's so fun yeah it was very fun
I got home yesterday wow were you there
the whole time no I was just there for a
week my aunt and my grandma came for
Christmas and that was sweet you see any
shows I did not I wanted to though I
know I know next time what the next time
I was just I I had a list of people I
had to see I see she's just so popular I
know true I mean you a girl of NYC it is
Olivia hey um we should go back to New
York sometime I would love to but yeah
our life with a baby coming El birth in
three months our life is like wow wow
anti- trvel right now that's true the
puppy and the boys and you're about to
give birth in 3 months we still don't
know a name which is really frustrating
yeah I don't think we ever we ever
updated cuz I see people still call the
baby Scotty but I was about to say we
kind of are we moved it to middle name
yeah interesting middle name Scotty okay
first name will be something else
however what happened what what happened
to Scotty um I wasn't really vibing with
it well I was like I was thinking maybe
I'm overthinking it but as a grown
person with the name and like
to name a person after a dog
yeah like I don't know I don't know if
you'll feel bad about that sure I love
Shredder more than I love Shredder as
much as anything I've ever loved I me
Scott is a normal name though like if it
was like Rover no yeah I but like oh
where'd you get your name from you know
people ask that oh yeah my parents named
me after their dog it's like really yeah
but so the middle name still honors our
our wonderful memory okay that's fair
it's fair
without without putting all that on him
everyone's saying
Oliver I like two wait what's going on
with with ducky oh he just pulled out of
he's such a punk he just pulled out of
his Le now he's running ducky ducky he's
a menace come here come here he's like
hell
no just so much
energy give him the Triceratops you know
he every time he starts acting up we
have this toy Triceratops uhhuh
here so Oliver is a no because it's also
way too popular and he it's like go down
on this on the two popular name list
Oliver has become really popular yeah
see he's going to do there he goes you
guys get the a front row
seat Well they can't see that not you
guys you yeah he he's getting his uh
frustrations out on the
catops yeah I agree Oliver's just too
popular of a name like whenever you look
at top names coming out right now Oliver
is always at like the top is it really
yeah I think it's become quite a popular
name I do oh yeah this the third most
popular baby name in 2022 crazy yeah
what's what's the number one and two uh
well this is specifically to Oliver but
this seems to have the info so let me
see give me a second
this is a deep data we're looking for um
yeah so I don't know Liam and Noah Liam
Noah Liam MH so there's G to be a whole
generation of
dudes who are just going to be named
Liam and Noah I already have seen a lot
of Liam in school and stuff like that
with Teddy and then you know and 50
years there's going to be old guy's name
like my dad Gary like that's such an old
guy name right but imagine a high school
of kids all walking around Gary smash
Gary Gary
Gary I don't think anyone gets Gary Liam
Noah Oliver James Elijah William Henry
Lucas Benjamin and Theodor actually is
number
10 that's the top 10 right now that was
us you're contributing we did
that yeah I mean of course I wanted to
name our son ducky Duckworth but
everybody Beats to that so the dog got
it yeah Ethan is 21 oh wow it was really
popular few Daniel's number 14 let's
go looks like
Daniel so I don't know so we have KN I
am and it's driving me crazy I'm trying
to think I don't like not knowing the
name yeah it's
frustrating
Zach
Zach that's a nice name what do you
think about Z why do you suggest that
it's the coolest name man true Zary it's
technically my brother's
name Zachary was he Zachariah Zach no
it's the way he adopted it to English it
became Zach but in Hebrew it's saki he
did a Ellis Island type of thing saki
turned into Zach yeah MH but yeah um
anyway
uh Zach how how you doing how you doing
um had a bit of an interesting break it
was good but um Bambi my dog had a
little accident um he's okay but um I
won't get into too much detailed we were
out of town for my dad's birthday he
turned 60 and the again KN going to name
person that was watching him was not
being responsible so Bambi jumped out of
a car window oh oh my god um he's okay
he was really beat up um so I spent
the other half of my break taking care
of him and me and Sh were taking care of
him and it's really really it was does
it's really it was really tough yeah I
bet how fast was the uh car going yeah
I'm still unsure about that there's
still holes to the story that I'm still
you got to be super pissed right you
have you have no idea yeah you have no
idea yeah um I would be yeah because you
know are they a dog owner the P this
person who did this do they have dogs
yes and I I cuz the window thing is very
like you have to really trust your dog
to put the window open all the way and
Bambi is this crazy you know yeah I
never do that for my dogs neither do
neither do we to the point where Shantal
has car seats for our dogs
um
so he he's he's okay he's okay he's
totally fine he's totally fine but it
was just really really scary and um you
know he he can't tell us that he's in
pain yeah the worst part so um it it was
really rough but other than that my B
break was good and um yeah how was the
vet bill was it crazy wasn't too bad oh
good really um okay we we rushed him um
over there I think it was only 100 bucks
for the uh the visit but yeah he he
there was nothing internal going on
thank God it was just some pretty gnarly
scratches and bres and he's they're
healing but it it was wow it was really
bad that's I'm sorry about that yeah but
he's doing okay
now these dog car seats I've never heard
of this before the the person yeah I I
got one at some point when we had only
Shredder in our life but he didn't like
it cuz he you can't they
can't he would not he was not down with
it Bambi and Priscilla they uh they love
him oh that's really they go right to
bed yeah that's okay huh so um what did
the person who did this have to say
about it did they try to defend
themselves at all it was utter stupidity
the the way they were trying to defend
it um and the fact that they did not
rush them to the vet oh immediately um
so wait how did they try to defend it if
I can ask and you can tell me if you
want me to stop I'll no he he claims
that uh Bambi got through a little
sliver of the window which just does not
seem
possible um yeah
I I can tell you more off air but um
yeah it was anyway we love you Bambi we
love you he's okay now he's okay now
love you bams any good
Legos um for I the last one I built was
for Hanukkah my parents got me the
Concord which I think I talked about on
air yeah um but no this break has just
been again like Dan I've I've kind of
just unplugged and good living off the
high of the uh the steamies oh yeah you
were the star of the show man Zach was
just absolutely shredded that whole
thing and the audio was so good looking
back at the show the live performances
were just they were phenomenal I mean
they sounded they looked and Zach you
were you were doing playing so well
everyone was super impressed thank you
it was great and a shout out to Sam and
Olivia for their performances and of
course the law man of course the law man
the Jersey law man Felix was amazing
great dude super nice dude but yeah
everyone knocked the uh the performances
out of the park so I'm really happy with
how it turned out nice overall I was
really happy with how the show went it
was nice to do it at the Dolby mhm that
theater is so professional it's so
polished it was like it was just another
level everything else we had done so I
definitely would be happy to do more
shows there you know yeah I was thinking
I know everybody wants us to do our show
at the
Greek uhhuh I'm still doubtful but if we
do I think what we can do is like summer
shows at degree winter shows the
steamies which I think should be
continue annually at the Dolby mhm
that's F right that'd be cool that'd be
cool I thought you were the one that was
hyped on the Greek
though sorry weren't you the one that
was hyped on the Greek I am it's just
there's I okay so on one hand I saw a
lot of people complaining about scalpers
which sucks the good thing about the
Greek is that there's so many seats and
also I think because there's so many
seeds we can even lower the prices
more uh and so the scalping game will be
like dead but my concern of course is
that we're not going to we're only going
to sell out is it that much more than
what we did at oh yeah it's like 6,000
or something uh the the scalper thing is
like it's it's a ticket Master thing and
it's just it I hate that company
so goddamn much yeah cuz they introduced
this thing where you can resell tickets
directly on their yeah no they've just
embra they're like okay we'll just we'll
be the scalpers now and it's so stupid
and the thing is is that a lot of these
venues the Dolby included have a
contract with them so you have to use
them yes our previous live show uh I
can't remember if both of them are just
one of them but we use like a smaller
independent ticketing thing and they
don't let they don't allow resales at
all and it completely qu like it's very
simple to quash the scalping thing but
Ticket Master doesn't want to
Monopoly you just make the yeah they're
the worst they have been and they
continue to be the worst yep so I guess
that's not going to change but if the
price is if the price is cheap and
there's tons of tickets then the
motivation to do that will be
significantly lowered true also all the
cowards who are trying to
uh to uh disrupt the show I didn't there
was not a single peep from you
cowards I don't know how serious that
ever was yeah I guess yeah maybe they
win just by making me think about it
about sometimes yeah the Reddit gang
well hi girls I know they're all here
they're the biggest fans hi girls we
love you thanks for
watching they're probably the ones
complaining when you're
late
Tomatoes um yeah other than
that uh the merch the dude the venue was
crazy with merch I did not like what
they did we got it all so set up and
streamlined and nice for everybody and
um I guess they didn't expect the volume
yeah I think they're not used to it
probably that's the only conclusion I'm
surprised by that the I mean I don't
want to air them out too publicly but I
don't think they care I mean they were
the there was a lot of conversations
about how busy it was going to be and
they still
somehow were acting like oh my God too
many people out here it's like we told
you there's going to be a million people
out here and like to be ready for that
well their response was first of all to
just shut down first of all they said no
Teddy fresh only and by the way they get
20% of all of our sales right that's
worth saying too yeah so first they go
no toy no Teddy fresh only H3 podcast
merch and then
they said no more they were're shutting
down the merch
Booth I was like what the but
thankfully um someone on our team was
able to convince the the manager two
hours later to reopen the merch Booth so
I apologize to everybody who got screwed
over by that I know I heard I saw people
saying they were waiting a long ass time
and then you know they saw all the
workers just standing around they didn't
understand what was happening right but
it was definitely it's it sucked it
sucked but I'm glad we were able to at
least open up oh yeah uh people Mr says
Ali was the sweetest ever yeah Ellie was
there my family was there they love
doing that I don't know why oh right
yeah your brother was uh sister-in-law
my sister I think also uhhuh yeah she
was out there my niece I think was there
hi sisters so they love that um anyway
and then the other big topic of
conversation was Tana of course
I'll say this about
tan at the time on stage I'll be totally
honest I didn't I didn't think anything
of it well there's also the sound issue
where we couldn't really hear each other
that well so I feel like a lot of the
stuff she said or we said the
communication was kind of like a myth
that was one of the big problem the
probably the only problem I think that
we'll have to address for next time is
having the making sure we have the
monitor speakers now we know and I'll be
honest I'm I'm not going to blame the
the venue they asked me at one point I
was we were prepping and they said do
you want do you need um monitor monitors
and I was like I don't think so I don't
know anything right I didn't even know
what a monitor is I said I don't think
so that sounds weird I don't need that
but obviously we did need that and
before the crowd filled the space that's
the we did contest and sounded totally
fine but then we did tons of sound tests
yeah we learn as we go y'all were loud
as hell yeah once it became full of
people all of a sudden it's like you're
talking and you can't hear anything it's
weird yeah speaking of audio at least
for for my end I have to give a shout
out to uh our production Crews audio
team they were awesome um they were
super super helpful and getting a good
mix and um I do have to give them a
shout out for that honestly I I'm going
to pull it up because the it looked
visually fantastic like oh man I was so
happy it looks so professional I mean
this the streamy are crying and
and pissing right now like first of all
we open with big tip hell yeah I think
everyone's probably watched it at this
point it's got 1.4 million views so
thank you guys everyone for tuning in
yeah that's really nice but the the
quality of the visuals was oh
Jesus you picked a great
frame randomly clicked and that had to
be it was update you want to see an
update back oh looks great it looks
great it looked so weird like for a few
days after did it uh did it burn or like
irritate at all or was it not at all huh
even growing back was fine wow okay
amazing n's the people said when it
grew back it was going to it was going
to be uncomfortable but I was fine but
like visually um it was so on point we
had like we had a crane we had sliders
for the cameras it was just're Al sweet
and we put get it the other something
cool together and Shout Out Sam for the
set as well turn out so good it looks so
good dude s the set looks so freaking
good when you see it from the long shots
which I'm trying to find it just it
looks phenomenal it really does yeah
there you go oh oh what the what
the freck what the freck what the
freak but I also want to thank all of
our our special guest
um Rich Lux P&P Rich was such he was the
highlight of the night I think sweetest
person such good energy yeah fantastic
Energy natural dude even his entrance
like off stage was so amazing I I asked
him if I could record it it was so good
for BTS sorry look at this shot who else
is doing this yeah it's gorgeous other
than that
Oscars look at that set in those lights
that's so beautiful I think we outdid
the Oscars by far the set was glowing
nobody watched the Oscars anymore yeah
that's true um that's so true so I was
saying yeah thank you to everyone I uh
Kevin the guy who nared me was awesome
honestly everyone was so nice and so
awesome and I'm very grateful that Jeff
and tana came and so I can't possibly be
angry at Tana for anything because I I
feel that uh I feel very uh happy that
she even that she came and did us a big
a big favor you know and shout out to
Logan Paul who the beef so big of him to
show up like that that was so Co he put
our petty dramas aside showed up he rode
for us so many of the parents backstage
were like is this really Logan
Paul and you were like yeah of course
yes Logan he's
here
um
so well I'm glad you were happy because
it was uh it was quite an undertaking I
got to say that was
one of the longest days of my life it
was a monster undertaking the leadup
time the prep the day of I mean really
was the crew uh
really went all out and I thank all you
guys for for the incredible effort here
thank you everybody on the team it's
special it really is I did not sleep a
wink the night before yeah that's wild
your plan I was pacing my apartment for
probably about 8 hours you killed it
thank you maybe this should give you
comfort if you can't sleep you can still
shred so you don't have to worry about
sleeping it doesn't matter if I sleep or
if you know cuz you shred it bro thank
you that performance was brought to you
by eight cups of coffee so dude I don't
know if I forgot my suit at home when I
went there in the morning yeah the suit
home and get it didn't you forget
something too
Ian no I was working on something I had
to go get oh okay
um but yeah so
Tana watching it back I see a lot of the
stuff that I guess made people upset
that I didn't even hear she was making
like all kinds of like a lot of suicide
jokes
yeah but um and then though I guess then
she was like defending James Charles but
and I made her she promised me that she
was going to disavow
him in her words she's just civil with
him and whatever you know I mean listen
uh I don't know what they you I can't be
mad at her I really can't I think I yeah
I think for us it's like we know how
busy other creators are and for anybody
to take their time out of their busy
schedule and come and do us such a favor
we're so grateful
that it's a really nice gesture yeah and
Jeff was awesome we love Jeff the family
loves Jeff and uh it was really a
special night really was so very good
very very good I mean So Pro man and uh
we'll keep refining it you know next
year we'll do the steamies again at the
Dolby hopefully and we'll just keep
it'll keep getting better hopefully you
know what I mean more exclusive too the
Stars will be showing up year after year
I'm telling you it's only matter of time
before Jay shett comes knocking on our
door and asking for tickets begging
begging
begging by the way J Shetty dropped the
Michelle Obama interview today who cares
bro I do our day you do I think America
watch the whole thing and I had to pause
it cuz we had to do this stupid show but
I'll be watching the rest later Jay I
think it was a sicilian message because
he knew it was our comeback episode and
you know H production started with
Michelle Obama and the intro that's true
he seriously had to drop the Michelle
Obama interview today like come on Jay
you had three weeks to do that leave me
the alone man dumbass loser
idiot I left a message of support from
the podcast account on
there
show me let's see here it is four likes
wow Shetty great moves keep it up proud
of you that's
sacrilege it's Michelle I had
to are we liking Michelle I mean are we
loving Michelle she is she all that I
don't know people really turned on Obama
I feel like did they I don't know
Michelle seems she seems great yeah
shees she seems nice she does seem great
got them she seems Timeless to me like
there's no she really is she does seem
like a great a great lady
yeah um so shout out to Michelle and
you
Jay it's come back if if uh Michelle
knew that he was bringing her on despite
us she probably would have asked to
delay it so she didn't know so don't
send any hate to Michelle yeah it's not
her fault she has more grace than that
yeah leave leave Michelle alone please
um Ian how was your break
uh it was it was okay I was sick most of
it what sick yeah I was sick for like 10
days I feel like that's on brand for you
Ian yeah I had like a really bad
flu Co I tested like five times to make
sure I think you had what I had like the
previous week before the steamies yeah
Zach was sick like the week before and I
wonder how you got it well I was sick
like two or three weeks before um but it
only lasted like 2 days you were really
sick for 10 days yeah I was in bed the
whole time oh my god dude what the
was there any like enjoyment cuz
sometimes like if you're not super super
super sick you get to just kind of veg
out and not feel
guilty uh it felt that way like the
other times when I had Co and stuff I
got caught up on a lot this time it was
just so bad yeah I was really zoned out
that sucks Sam was in Georgia so I was
like
alone it's brutal PO he was suffering
alone I was like going so stir crazy so
the moment I felt better I um I
immediately booked a flight and I flew
out to Georgia and I spent a week with
that's nice that's really nice well I'm
glad you got sick on your break and not
during the show yeah if you had missed
work we might have had to fire youate
for me grind doesn't stop yeah could you
like were you at least like binging
movies or something could you do
anything yeah I was playing a lot of
video games and stuff and I've watched
five Fast and the Furious movies in one
day let's go d
which five the first five I've never
seen it you never seen them no five is
when it starts to get really good my
friend I'm not kidding well do you did
you like them Ian the first like two are
pretty they're not bad they're
interesting but then they move away from
the so good the
racing they move away from the racing
and what they they focus more on like
doing like heists and stuff like crimes
they're doing all kinds of crimes dude
did you like that pivot or no no no okay
interesting yeah a lot of games and then
um Sam and I we hung out with her
parents the whole week and we took a
trip to North Carolina as well and that
was really fun nice nice yeah love that
I salvaged it AIT I'm glad I'm
glad um Sam is not here cam is not here
he's GNA be gone this week
um for personal reasons I mean I'm not
he's fine yeah he's good he's fine yeah
yeah he's not you know nothing to worry
about but yeah he'll be back next week
um and then he can tell you guys about
his
break but I think did I ask everybody
did I forget
anybody I think I think we covered it
all I think we got it did you watch
Tokyo Drift Ian yeah yeah that's the uh
that's the third one Tokyo Drift that's
the but there's a confusing thing where
there's second one's Too Fast Too
Furious two there's two then Tokyo Drift
is actually five movies in the future I
think yeah the timeline is very
complicated in the past and Furious and
then there's four movies that go back in
time before Tokyo Drift then they Circle
back right wow so you need a whole I
have a chart at if you want I have a
whole
whiteboard that's so I don't know when
you read like deep deep fantasy books
and lore there's these like really
really elaborate timelines of everybody
trying to put things together like on uh
for example berserk I see that a lot
yeah right so I that's great that um The
Fast and the Furious is such an
elaborate uh Universe to pull from yeah
there's so much there's so much more
there's so much more and yeah I mean you
don't even you don't even meet uh the
rock until like the fifth movie and he's
he's become a pivotal character in the
whole story speaking of um Fast and
Furious Vinnie our boy Vinnie got and
got into happen what happened no what
did Vinnie do I think he got some essay
stuff happening yeah there was some
allegations who could have who would
have expected that I mean we all watched
him do that on camera coming very openly
I think people are now starting to look
back at all the interviews that we've
been watching for years
right being like yo what the hell it's I
can't do this any damn what happened
what did he do okay well that that was
the video was more harassment this is a
an accusation of assult Sal so this is
more serious oh so he and that's from
aned of sexual battery no from a former
assistant I'm seeing yeah it was while
working on Fast
5 yeah sorry sorry weird bad time to
watch your face that was a bad Marathon
timing there you got skip can't cat
bre yeah so I don't know Vin is just the
weirdest dude alive so and I
mean you know uh just stole a was bad
ducky you're such a
punk there he goes all right you got
your own the a flack dog yeah for real H
so I guess I
mean we can still say
family and the thing is Vinnie was
always we were it was always kind of
yeah the joke was that he's a creep he's
crazy
so we're on the same page the world is
just catching up to us really exactly
exactly beautiful world I'm in beautiful
world
yeah um all right all right uh we should
do our ad break oh yeah we have an ad we
do how unusual we're back baby so let me
think our one sponsor quickly and then
we'll get on with the main thrust of
today's show and I will be thrusting
hard thank you to stamps.com you know
them you love them they've been such a
great supporter of ours and I love
stamps.com um why would you use
stamps.com why would Dan's girlfriend
use stamps.com why wouldn't she and and
and I mean I trust her choice cuz she's
very bright she's very dedicated
hardworking if she's using it it's for a
good reason right Dan absolutely yeah
only the best only the best does she get
a kick out of this whole thing she
thinks it's so I mean yes yeah she does
yeah it's turned into a meme at this
point but but she really is a a Avid
mailer of things she mails so much yeah
it'sa true you know 2024 is here uh you
never know what's going to happen what
you might need to mail what occasions
who's going to die send a condolence
card or be born or be born right true
that's events yeah you can get knocked
up and give birth all in one one year
you never know but here's what you do
know for all that stuff you're going to
need to be mailing stuff that's where
stamps.com comes in to the picture did
you know stamps.com gives you crazy
discounts up to 89% they updated now
89% up to 89% off USPS and UPS Services
that's almost 90% dude because they have
these dude the prices to ship stuff when
you're not doing it like through a
channel like if you're just a an
individual that goes into the it's so
expensive it's crazy yeah and but yeah
if you do it via one of these
big uh groups they can negotiate they do
negotiate heavily down the price because
of the volume yeah so you're going to
get a massive discount um and if it
doesn't matter if you got a small
business a big business whatever it is
stamp.com is the way to do it they're
going to save you time and money here's
how it
works you download it you get your scale
your digital scale you put the package
on the
scale you weigh it so you get the exact
postage you print the postage you put it
on the
package they'll come get
it yeah yeah yeah they'll you don't even
have to do anything they'll come get it
you can put it in your mailbox you put
in a Dropbox you can just leave it at
your door and schedule a pickup uh the
time the money savings it's really a
no-brainer and they these guys have been
uh helping small businesses all
businesses over 25 years over 1 million
businesses these guys are the real deal
yeah really really real a lot of
business so we love stamps take a chunk
out of your mailing and shipping cost
this year with stamps.com sign up at
stamps.com
h3v for a special offer that includes a
4-we trial plus free postage and a free
digital scale there's no long-term
commit commments or contracts just go to
stamps.com
h3v thank you to stamps and please
consider
supporting our wonderful sponsors oh
that music sore is that a new one Zach I
think so uh I've I've had this in here I
just don't play it as often so New Year
something baby yeah baby what you up
oh stamps stamps stamps
let's go all right thank you also
quickly there's a sale going on a Teddy
fresh winter sale uh cozy cozy
sale cozy sale it's been cold boy it's
winter out
here um yeah just a little sale on the
do how do I get to the sale the sale
page here um yes oh it's not really
advertise on the main page very much is
it should probably be oh here it is cozy
SES star now up to 40% off selected
items oh here's the Cozy sale okay it's
cozy there's basically all the outerwear
the Cozy fun warm stuff the sweaters the
sharpa the heavier stuff nice so you
know what if you need something warm if
you need something cool if you need
something fresh hip exciting head over
to ted.com see if there's something you
like and there's a lot of stuff here
really a lot of stuff oh that's hot it
is hot thank you Willie
wiie booss slick Willie Style a lot of
them are going to be having very little
amounts of sizes there so mhm so get in
there
now
um all right I mean
[Music]
shoot there's okay there's a few little
things like the 54 Manor uh you know man
54 man this whole thing was pretty good
there you know the whole
um there was another thing I wanted to
talk about oh yeah but what what you
want to talk about that Zach because you
inter you um interacted with
him I was nothing but nice and we were
accommodating as much as possible to him
okay so wait let actually let me watch
this video okay so we were going to have
the 54 Manor come and perform live his
band mhm um I thought it was going to be
pretty pretty cool I was excited
actually um and in fact I thought he was
going to be excited too because he was
very much when we first started talking
about him like super sto absolutely um I
I guess watch the video and I can tell
you more what happened so here here here
he is talking about what happened gear
they wouldn't tell us what I'm going to
refresh it here and try to humiliated in
front of thousands of people I think
here let me explain if you've ever heard
of H3 podcast I just found this today
cuz I heard that tx2 was nominated for
an award best influencer song So H3
asked me to perform my song I would hate
me too at the reward show in La about a
month or two ago I know H3 likes to meme
on things though so I ended up actually
getting on the phone with them and
asking them will this be a meme cuz I am
totally cool with that and they said no
they assured me that this was going to
be a serious performance of my song but
here's where things got weird they said
that I could not bring a drummer to a
rock show at the Dolby Theater because
they didn't have space they also said we
couldn't bring any of our own gear they
wouldn't tell us what audio visuals they
were going to play behind us and they
gave us little information about it so I
proceeded to ask more and more questions
you you can see that he's just so
annoying oh yeah oh I think he's pissed
cuz he up he himself so
bad now that I'm here to comment on this
we were not planning a goof on you man
mm-m not at all nope I don't know what
you just showed but if you watch the
award show everybody who performed
was it wasn't done uh in any other way
than to celebrate it exactly he
himself so bad I mean the winner was Sam
right of the song of the year I thought
so too and like this comment bro your
song is ass be happy be happy that
you're even getting the publicity of
having it
played I would I wouldn't say that um
but that person
did but no it was I thought this was a
good opportunity for them to come and
win people over and do a whole I was
excited but so Zach you tell me what
happened let me finish let me finish I'm
performing I wanted to know what I was
doing but right after my call with Zach
from H3 the last communication I had
with them was them telling me that I was
no longer needed and that they didn't
want me to perform anymore all for me to
find out this the song that got me into
tx2 after heard it on Tik Tok and I
shouted about the song with him when I
interviewed him it took off a life of
its own online with both lots of love
and hate coming in against it and I do
know this was a serious song for him to
write about a serious topic I watched
hold on I'm a 54 manhor is a serious
song about a serious topic why would you
even try to argue
that hold on this is can we please take
this
seriously I wrote this song to to change
the
world further realize who some of the
awards are up against like Colleen
Ballinger's apology song I mean that in
itself that shows what this category was
and then I was like oh joke Cate check
out the you saw this whoever the I
don't know who this guy is or did he
look at any of the other ones I mean you
know it was it wasn't all just people we
didn't like the majority was people we
did like I think plus I I uh replic ated
the songs to do them Justice and and you
know we wanted a awesome performance and
I think that's what it was song nice
title influencer song I would hate me I
was almost publicly humiliated bro
frankly I think you're way Clos to being
publicly humiliated in front of
thousands of people right now yes than
you would have ever
been uh performing so Zach tell me he
told he he said said
that um you we were very restrictive
about his uh yeah so I guess the
timeline uh Olivia reached out to him
and then Olivia loot me in because he
had some questions about technical stuff
and you know musician to musician
and um he's like okay um he's like this
sounds great uh the first interest call
he's like can I bring my guitar player
with me I'm like yeah that that doesn't
seem to be a problem sure why not um so
it was getting closer to the show date
and I'm like Hey man can we hop on a
call go over details blah blah blah and
he's like uh can I bring my own rig with
me can my guitar player
bring his uh his rig with me and it was
a real simple setup it wasn't just an
amp it was through the the house I'm
like yeah that that's easy he's like can
we run our own tracks I'm like I don't
think that's going to work because
they're tied into the video Loops dude
the the the logistics of it is this is
not a
live uh this is not set up for a band
it's set up for a really complicated
live variety show that includes music
right and I I should I'll jump in here
and just say that uh ultimately it was
the the way that I designed the tech
flow of the show uh because there are so
many moving parts and you know because
it's first time that we're doing
something like this I wanted to keep
things very streamlined and very simple
which is why you know Zach performed all
the songs that way we only had to sound
check just his one setup which is just
an amp just one amp right and play to
tracks and everything um you know it was
not a full band setup and it wasn't for
any of the other songs and we were
already making exceptions for him like
Zach just mentioned of him bringing in
his own guitar player was like okay yeah
fine you can do that and they want to
use their own gear okay fine you can do
that um but then I mean and sorry to
interrupt you were about to get into it
but he was then wanting to bring a
drummer and everything and frankly at
that point um he was just being so needy
and whiny and the show was already
scheduled to run really long uh I I
think I was the one that ultimately was
like let's let's just cancel this dude
it's like nobody gives song anyways
I was advocating for you like throughout
the whole thing there was talks of like
let's just drop it it's not worth the
effort cuz he's being a mega Diva and
like he's just not that it's not that
important the the part that really threw
it over the edge where I called Dan I'm
like we got to we got to do something
about this he's like okay I'm going to
bring my own microphone that plugs into
the PA system and he this is the part
that that really frustrated me he's like
we've been over so many times by
Audio guys that we want to run our own
sound I'm like dude we're not doing some
shitty yeah we're not doing some
bar gig I'm like dude as a
fellow musician you got to learn
sometimes you got to learn to do on
the Fly you're a performer get out there
and perform you know so you gave
him a pep talk I'm I wasn't like going
off on him but like I'm like dude
there's this is a big deal and he asked
multiple questions he was so concerned
we were going to with him and I
kept reassuring him dude we're not going
to do that I I understand why you might
think that but I don't I I really wanted
him to understand I don't know how to
tell him that it wasn't going to be like
that right he I understand why he would
feel that way though I I wish Evan this
his name Evan the best but he really
himself here and I think he made
the video because you saw how legit and
cool the performances were
so I
you took took your lucky break in Toran
too my friend I'm just well it's all
right he's he'll he'll find great
success he's a Manor dude what
are we what are we talking about here
dude he's 5'4 he's not even human bab
this is a serious song okay he's barely
even a human being at
54 please anyways um so yeah nobody
would have ever even mentioned it or
talked about it but uh he decided to
post that video so I guess we got to
explain what happened I thought it was
funny because the whole the whole back
story was funny yeah and bro I was
advocating for the whole time I was
like even after everyone was like let's
just drop him it's not worth it I said
let's just get let's give him one more
chance let's get him on the phone just
explain that you know it's the Dolby
we're working with what we have the best
we can and and we really really tried to
accommodate him which is why I find it
whatever anyway shout out to uh shout
out shout out tx2 blaby
you tx2 I'm more of a fan of
r.m if we're just talking about
three did that makes sense right rx2 is
just three digits no I just who's that
again r.m is
the he would probably come out oh he
would definitely we got get m. out dude
for sure at the Greek at the Greek
he deserves that too I think he's great
I love
him 100% come to it and he wouldn't give
a that dude performs that song
anywhere anytime drop of the Hat he's in
a 7-Eleven he'll that's a
perform dude when opportunity
knocks you got to go honestly Tom Ward's
going to go to was willing to go to
fistf Fest you know what I mean like
right oh he was not more than
willing whatever happened with that by
the way it's it's not no it's gonna
happen I've been uh back and forth with
hunger and we just got to come up with
more logistic things but I think it I
know a lot of people getting they think
it's like weird and stuff but I want to
say everybody participating this it's
it's all everybody's happy with what's
happening there there's no hunger knows
exactly what we do we're friends with
him we respect hunger we like hunger we
got approval from the fist Fest board to
do yeah the bo the board approv board of
director yeah so listen to me it's just
a really interesting wild
Niche uh culture it really is and um I
think it's fascinating and I think it'
be super super a great segment yeah and
I'm excited to be working with Tom more
too he was sending me some ideas he is
very excited and it sounds oh man that's
awesome I do love they said no girls
allowed though that was awesome were
pretty girls I was so excited about
Olivia and Sam thank you me too they
said no girls allowed
maybe I get it maybe I get it it's just
everybody's doing it's for the boys dude
it's for the boys women not do it no no
it's a it's a it's a gay man event no I
understand but the the action the ACT I
think
so I mean anatomically I don't think
there's a difference okay of the the
fisting right yeah no that's
that
that all genders for everyone it's just
not for it's just for gay dudes those
this event is for is for gay men
okay girls have coties what can you what
can you do I mean girls have cooties
dude it's for the boys it's for the
boys um is there any other little dramas
I need to touch on oh there's probably a
ton but oh I wanted to give a big shout
out I'm about to focus on the hater and
all this and you know mhm as we get
this new year started and you guys know
I am the messiest on
YouTube we know girl girl we
know um that I want to give a shout out
to somebody who made such a nice video I
mean this was really really nice thing
tall skeleton who I've mentioned before
did you guys watch this uh I uh yeah I
watched the first uh like 10 minutes of
it um yesterday we watched the whole
thing last night you should you guys
should all watch it cuz it's super
complimentary towards all I watched this
very good um it was so well made and
uhar the following video hundreds of
hours of research recording and editing
that I believe insane insane that's a
that's a deep cut right there I love I
saw I mentioned or I I noticed this the
xqc yeah but um it's so good and I it's
so nice and uh I feel that you know we
are very Innovative and we are very
hardworking in the space and it's nice
to be appreciated for that it's nice to
see a positive video lots of love to uh
you Dan I don't know if you watched the
part about you he was very impressed
with the technical aspect of everything
he get didn't get to that part he gets
into pretty good nitty-gritty about
certain things that you're able to pull
off that that are very impressive cool
yeah I watched Ian part and the Zach
part I think were the first two
parts I mean really oh I don't know but
he really it's just cool to see somebody
appreciate everything all the details
it's rare it's cool yeah it's really
cool in my
life it does not exist doesn't exist so
when it happens let's let's celebrate
them sure but I it's a great watch H
stre podcast the most Innovative show on
YouTube by tall skeleton we'll put the
link in the description I guess and pin
it and stuff so yall can watch it oh uh
sure I'll put it in the description
right now yeah shout out a couple of
people asked about the Salt Lake City
finale I don't know if you want to talk
about it cuz I know we have we have a
lot to talk about but well just to
paraphrase it without getting into it
one of the girl new cast members cuz
Shaw went to prison for fraud or I think
fraud something like that tax evasion or
something right yeah and so they brought
in a new character and she's super messy
uh apparently anyway so at the
finale it comes out that she's been
running a snark Instagram account
account about all of them and like
really nasty a te account that's
been torturing them for like four years
they all know immediately the account
they all know and hate this account and
they find out she's been behind it the
whole time one of the cast members yes
yes the the new she's a new girl on the
C infiltrated yo that's crazy has DMs I
guess they she got to it wait the
producers knew the producers had no they
did I swear they got so what happened
was um Heather is that who it is yeah so
she got to the bar I guess her Barber
ended up snitching on her or hairdresser
hairsty the hairdresser apparently was
also a part of it which is kind of
shitty too but they handed over all
these DMs like her saying I'm going to
infiltrate them what was an inside job
on wow she had a goal crazy and that
that last episode was like one of those
great moments of Television it's just
like the way I love that they get kind
of goofy with the editing on Salt Lake
City for some reason cuz just they're so
dramatic but it's a little bit aware
which I love so the whole episode was so
dramatic from the beginning they're like
Heather's got this big it was and it was
so big and like as they were the thing
is you could tell as real life as
they're starting to confront her and
it's getting heated you can see
producers running around in the back
obsessed panicking cuz it's just getting
crazy no wait AE wait a minute wait a
minute and then Heather was like get out
of here it was so powerful because it's
the last episode of the go ahead hater
Dan I see what you're up for no no no
I'm not I don't doubt that the the other
ladies didn't know but as far as the
producers not knowing how could they
know how could they not here here's the
um there's thousands of tea things to
tell you by the way but I'll let you
finish okay so this is Salt Lake City
Housewives right so this new cast member
is a Salt Lake City housewife she's
married she's like a rich divorced
divorc and she lives in Salt Lake City I
don't know how rich she is she's not
she's actually not that rich um except
for like Beverly and New York some of
the other housewives are not rich at all
they're all it's just a show about
divorc angry people middle-aged women uh
cuz like how yeah if why do you think
they would know nobody knew there's
thousands of because that's why you
would bring that random person onto the
show no they bring she was um she was
like related she worked for Jen Shaw who
was previously on the show that's the
one that went to jail right yes so she
worked with okay she worked with her in
the past so I guess she's like huh in
the circle okay okay these these women
have been running like private
detectives trying to figure this out so
if if the show knew they would have
known too okay maybe maybe it was real
and then okay your name came up then
because yes I was talking to no I was
talking to tati my friend about the
housewives and she was telling me that
she act because she grew up near Orange
County um she was friends with the
daughters of
Shannon Shannon the crazy Shannon from
Orange Housewives Shannon Shannon she
was the one the with the boyfriend who
pretended to have cancer no that's Vicky
the other one oh that was Vicki shann is
the one that got divorc
shanor yeah that okay yeah okay yes so
tati's friends with her daughters and
she was there when they were filming and
stuff and it's all very real yeah
real still real to me damn
it first evidence from the crime scene
firsthand huh fir hand evidence real to
me okay still real to me Dam I mean if
they were there anyway and I said to
myself Salt Lake City continues to be
the undefeated king of this series well
Queens Queens of this series thank you
right from the Jens Shaw arrest now to
this I mean it's like they keep giving I
mean that's a that is an epic moment to
have the biggest hater sneak into the uh
into the cast regardless of if it's
planned not like don't get me wrong even
if the producers were in on it that's
hilarious that they put her in
there true yeah all I'm saying is Andy
Cohen knows exactly what he's doing
absolutely possible he's a genius ab and
Lena you guys are up to date on Salt
Lake right no we actually were going to
start it over a break we watched Vander
pump you know Vander P but what you're
saying is like crazier than Scandal I
think Scandal was overblown yeah there's
been cheating scand on the on the show
before but like what you're talking
about now is totally different dude the
Jack's cheating scandal was the way
crazier than any of that yeah mhm
mhm anyway maybe it's just cuz Scandal
is such a good name it is
catchy it's bonus points for that yeah
Salt Lake City that's the one man so I
cannot wait for the
reunion all right anything else to touch
on before we enter the uh Abyss the
abyss
um it's going to take us all week to to
get through the yeah let's just get into
it then let's just all right let me open
the dock I've got here jump right into
it actually you know what apologies I'm
going to go PE and then we'll get into
it okay because I want to just no
interruptions how bad do you have to pee
right now
very uh somebody uh donated 20 bucks
just a moment ago and said sent you a
new C music video titled baby Bruce
versus C Cav really what xmus present
for the H3 fam and all good fun uh daddy
Brad the bull makes a rare appearance
all right well we'll have to check it
out thank you uh the evil the evil eye
effect shout out um and there was one
other oh yeah you have them in here
don't you okay so Ela Andy does the
reunion for Salt Lake as well mhm oh
he's everywhere he does it for all of
them he does it all I didn't know that I
like and for below deck oh
wow that's his show too yeah super
producer I did not know that he really
is a genius I love that
show wow yeah it's
crazy uh Bella Simmons uh gifted 50
memberships oh Bella the queen thank you
Bella always coming in big like that
thank you Bella uh Zach my cousin SLB
boy just got a job at Lego let me know
if you want that employee discount
hookup yeah dude Dan you better
read this I read it our house has become
such a Lego house there's no shelf or
countertop left with no Lego on it it
sounds like my place yeah it's crazy and
I can't blame Teddy it's like I'm part
of the problem too it's addicting it's
addicting it's uh it opens your mind to
Great possibilities honestly only thing
that he'll sit with for like hours and
just be content that's awesome that's ni
that's awesome I might need to give them
a try I heard they're coming out with
the Twilight Lego collab they
are Twilight Lego yep isn't it like 10
years too late for that it's never too
late yeah no it's like right on time
they just put out new Lord of the Ring
you know I got my mom don't compare
lord of the r I'm I would never I would
never I'm just saying The Lego company
is they like doing that okay it's a
throwback it's a throw they are so good
I I bought actually one that was
offbrand for Theodore because he wanted
a fire truck and like that one looked
really cool mhm and oh my God it's so
super so inferior to
the% to the actual Lego stuff the
bootleg I kind of like it though because
it's like you can
get like there's just a lot more options
there's more options but the experience
terrible is is it bootleg bootleg or is
it like another brand there it's
literally Legos there isn't Like
official brand like definitely be
illegal it's brick brick blocks or
something like that it's called oh don't
pretend like you don't know Z it's the
other side of the aisle at Target let's
just put it that
way you have to and the the like pieces
are sharp and they hurt your fingers the
instructions were horrible it's just not
the same no Lego knew they know what the
up they what they're doing I know
what they're doing Lego's having a
moment and now they're having this
flower serious which I sent to my mom
and now my mom is hooked on Lego really
Sean tall's mom got me that for
Christmas yeah oh you started the flower
yeah did you like the experience
um it I I like the Star Wars and I
like the uh like the the planes are cool
and I mean it it the flower is a
lot more intricate say I see all right
so let's talk about this dude Jake do
better got him
dude so there's all these weird wrinkles
in this
story let's start from the top here we
love wrinkles Jake
dittle made a video called Ethan
Klein um harmful or
hypochondriac in which he amongst other
things accuses me of the whole lupus art
that we've been going through of me
trying to like figure out what's wrong
with me he accuses me of lying about
being sick to make money which is
bananas as I'll get into bananas a how
he knew that and is so accurate in his
assessment it's crazy how did he know
how did he know he an Insider he's an
Insider I have a big reveal Salt Lake
City Style I am Jake dittle oh my God
what the is this really bro you're
going to really say that about Gypsy
Rose she was being poisoned by her mom
that's just not cool he said it about
her too Gypsy Rose harmful of hyperia
act oh my God that's not cool
[Laughter]
man God but the whole video is just a
bizarre really weird personal attack and
a really strange
gatekeeping of um chronic illness
MH and um the really interesting wrinkle
is that this guy's been a huge fan of
ours and actually there's been a ton of
interactions of him trying to reach out
and get notice and get
attention from almost everybody on the
crew
um here's why I don't feel bad talking
about this one when he put out a
teaser right before we went on
break all the comments were like this is
this isn't a good idea like Ethan does
have stuff and he that all the lupus
stuff is just joking and like every
single comment was pretty much like
don't do this
also AB tell because when you saw that
you told me that you think it's just a a
joke because it's such a silly premise I
was like there is no way there's
cuz I kind of seen him passing but I
thought it was just he was click baiting
you for the teaser of something
unrelated sort of the way that idub said
his content cop on Rice gum he called it
Jake Paul content cop I thought it was
going to be something like that but I
was
wrong I think we all slowly realized
like holy this guy's being serious
cuz he started answering to comments
like oh yeah there was like some random
person like I have Lupus and this and I
thank you for everything you're doing
and he's like I'm making this video for
people like you and we're like oh
he's being serious
is so AB from a place of kindness cuz I
knew the minute I saw him doing
this that it was going to make him look
really bad and really dumb mhm and
ab kindly reached out to
him and said hey just so you
know this is really weird that you're
doing that that's it and he used it
against us in his video hold on yeah I
was asking him if it if this was just
clickbait or if he was serious about it
and I when he told me he was serious I'm
like as a fan you know that sounds
insane right like that sounds
insane but again as I'm record yeah here
here's him talking about it and again I
want to watch the whole thing trust me
guys it's going to be fun it's going to
be fun but here he is talking about ab's
message to himing this yesterday I
posted a teaser to this video and I've
received more backlash than I've gotten
in a very long time so much so that
somebody from the H3 crew direct
messaged me and called me insane for
thinking this I also so I mean that's
that's a pretty charged statement
and I mean but that that's not exactly
what happened it's not exactly what
happened I'll show the uh people
correctly guessed that it was
AB thank you AB
yeah um here's the a exchange or here's
the exchange so you guys can see it this
is pretty good right like I can't even
and by the way as a fan of the show you
know I'm the pettiest dirt uh messiest
online how is he a fan I don't know well
I'll go through it he's like a mega fan
wild it's wild it's wild to me like the
joke you
know it's he's like the worst type of
person online in that he's a fan of this
show and we do a we push the The Edge
and we're super off iive on a daily
basis yet when I lightly brush against
the one thing that he knows about all
the sudden it's uh
mhm it's a full-on Revolt like bro you
didn't care about all the other
yeah you just you got to stick up for L
he he said apparently in one time in the
video I was stealing lupus
Glory Loop is Glory what the so
here's the text message ABY you want to
read it I can read it you can read it so
AB texted him and you guys were on
talking terms you guys even did a collab
together yep I I'll hold off on that but
this is why I don't do collabs
my one and only collab course this is
why I told him no no no no no
I'm going to hold off go ahead I'll wait
you can do them maybe it's fine I know
but this is why I don't I know you're
okay with it I know you're okay with it
but this was exactly my fear and
the first person I do it with this
happens and the the he does
it the day we go on break so I got to
stress about it all break too
I'm going to hold off go ahead yeah I'll
I'll say as a footnote here this came
out right after we went on break and
when I watched this I I was honestly
pretty upset by it and um I wanted to
react so
bad uh do an Ethan Klein video but I'm
I'm really glad that I restrained myself
enjoyed my break and now I can come back
and and talk with all you guys about it
so I'm glad that
uh I restrained myself and waited until
now I was impressed with you because I I
held off on watching it all the way
through until last night and I was
infuriated so I haven't watched it still
haven't watched L didn't make it through
impossible And he as a fan he knew to do
it right before break because that's
when you put out your Ethan Klein videos
I believe you think he was wanting the
reaction yes I think he underestimated
the response I thought he probably
thought he would get some you know push
back but nothing that serious and then
he would bait you into responding well I
think yeah there's there's like a huge
market for Ethan hate videos so like he
I think if you're trying to tap into
that you'll probably piss off some of
our fans who are defensive of me and
then you'll probably get a whole bunch
of new fans yeah who are like I hate
Ethan you know but I don't think he got
anyone uh I even see I saw people on
social media who like are straight up
like um do not like me being like what
the hell was the point of that
video anyway AB says I'm assuming your
new video is clickbait LOL he responds
hey buddy as someone who has dealt with
chronic illness and has a nonprofit for
people with chronic illness I have to
talk about it the goal is not to cancel
anybody but lying about doctors thinking
he has lupus self- diagnosing on the
show comparing lupus to other quote more
serious diseases and getting donations
in support of a diagnosis he doesn't
have is the problem with online self
diagnosis and feeding on sympathy after
reading after speaking to women who are
suffering financially and physically
from this illness I decided to make this
video you're not mentioned at all but I
will be saying how I have relationships
with people around him and don't that by
the way that was a lie he said I mean he
didn't say your name but he definitely
snitched on you yeah and uh uh blah blah
blah he says I will be saying that I
have relationship with people around him
and I don't want that to jeopardize
anything okay so AB said that's insane
dude as a viewer I'm honestly shocked
that you would take uh that seriously in
any way possible you did not call him
insane you said that is insane like the
take is insane it's an insane take yeah
so uh oh did that just come up now oh
Jake's gonna make a
sequel members go up just gave €250 EUR
man no charge that back bro I I'm not
trying to steal lupus glory for L for
Ethan's lupus sorry j what are you
doing no you're getting us in trouble
sorry Jake belittle it I hope you saw he
usually doesn't disclose taking 90% from
his Charity's merch profits oh that okay
I wasn't even going to go there with the
guy you know I'm not trying to I'm
trying to temper I'm trying to keep it
to the point I'm not trying to like go
in and ruin this guy's whole
life so that being being
said this guy's going to look like a
real idiot when we're done and
then the third and final point that I
don't feel bad is that it's still on his
YouTube channel look at this idiot I
said I didn't even say anything I put
out one
little yesterday I put out an insta
story where is
it where is it uh your insta story from
yesterday yeah
I'll pull it up here I got it right here
oh here this that beeping is you right
his has both heart rate monitor that's
what I thought yeah just making sure oh
it's getting confused his has both so
literally all I posted was my face when
I'm excited to return to the podcast
tomorrow with his
face there smiling nicely sweetly and
that was how I felt D didn't say
anything else didn't say anything about
him the whole break nothing
and here's what he
responded he says I will do anything to
make this stop dude it's on your channel
it's still up on your channel what the
are you talking about I didn't even
say anything about you it's still on
your channel clearly you not doing if he
would have removed it during the break I
wouldn't I wouldn't have cared I would
have by the time the break came I was
very kind of my emotions had simmered
and I was like not really I wasn't angry
anymore so if he had removed it I would
not be doing
this I'm thankful on one hand that he
didn't because this is f good
content he says I will do anything to
make this stop uh the death threats
telling me to kill myself and saying I
was never sick in the first place is
something I cannot handle I was trying
that's literally what you did to me in
your video but okay I was trying to make
a video from the perspective of a sick
person and didn't connect with everyone
I was in the hospital last week after
posting the video and I legitimately
cannot handle anymore I apologize to
everyone involved so obviously you
know don't send death threats that's
crazy um and don't you know be mean
however I do notice this trend of people
by the way this man made a video making
a super personal attack on meh knowing
that I'm messy and then when I
just show his
face he wants he he's he's like no no no
no someone had a good analogy it's like
when your little brother punches you and
then and then when you're going to hit
him back he goes no no no no no no I'm
done I'm done fight's over yep like bro
come on you made your
bed and now you got to you got to sleep
in it and again it's still on your
channel yeah the first how you say
you've done anything to make St do
anything to make this stuff do what make
what stuff I don't even know oh oh he
just private it well it's too late bro
late is it now no it's too late it's too
late you had all three weeks to
do it man he's watching I'm assuming
yeah probably Jake you had three weeks
and every comment on the video was like
this is a bad take social media this is
a bad take nobody liked nobody was down
with it and it took him until now for
for some reason when I'm here actually
defending myself like bro you have a
public video up with like 125,000 views
and people that aren't familiar with me
in my show can take away a really nasty
impression of me so of course I'm I have
every single right to come here and
respond and the fact you just took it
down now is not going to save you
brother you might as well just bring it
back
up public that you know it
don't worry we have backups yeah of
course we downloaded it don't worry Jake
we've got it well of course we
downloaded it because my
immediate expectation is that he's going
to erase this we got him and he didn't
almost a whole month he did not so but
yeah we download why is he doing this
it's so embarrassing bro but I mean you
guys haven't even seen the video and how
mean spirited is and stuff see bits and
peace excuse me so then like before I
even watch the video there's weird stuff
to get to so here's a background of his
weird fan Behavior first time he ever
called into the show he called into the
show and I didn't know this there was a
scandal some of you guys might
remember James was oh no the deelo
Apparently ripped off a photographer
that did work for them and I brought him
on and I said hey I'm going to pay you
for the money they didn't give you like
500 bucks was him yeah that was him yeah
whoa so here I'm going to play the clip
I don't know but stay on the line I'm
going to send you $500 cuz the demilio
family
didn't that was a nice gesture
right family didn't pay you 500 I'm
going to pay because they're cheap
freaks it's like a Romeo jul or
their team is well yeah so you stay in
the line okay thank you very much I'm
going to make you I have a question go
ahead I have a question go ahead if uh
if uh if you look over my resume can you
keep your $500
stay in the line are you in La you hear
me groan we had a nice I was groaning in
my mind yeah because like here I'll play
it again Dan we can hear Dan grum that's
how exactly what I felt I was like we
just had a nice
moment why you it up dude just
take the 500 man yo somebody just
donated two bucks and said do little too
late
nice I love I'm so sorry thank you sexy
trash Panda Jake do better
$500 stay in the line that was good that
was good are you in La he did say he was
subscribed I'm not in La I'm remote but
love I bet you I could kill it okay so
I'm going to give you the 500 I'm gonna
give you I didn't want to even deal with
it but I like so that that was his wow I
had an one interaction with him that was
it which happens to be so generous so
funny and you know what just cuz I did
something generous for him doesn't mean
he can't criticize me sure but like it's
just funny because he brings it back to
money like you're faking illness for
money that is one of the dumbest points
in this whole video because throughout
the whole lupus thing as you guys
remember I donated quite a bit of money
to people for their medical bills well
exceeding the amount of donations I got
during that time of but anyway we'll get
into the nitty-gritty of that here's the
application he sent
us
um it's pretty long oh and and just lots
of persistent and again again not on the
on this alone is doesn't say anything
because I've talked about how
persistence has gotten true uh people
jobs on here before
so I am not uh saying that but he did
send the resume and lots of follow-ups
now it continues AB met him at creater
Clash you want to talk take the ball AB
uh yeah I mean I wish he didn't delete
his messages between me so I can
remember the flow of things but uh you
know he was nice and I recognized him
from calling the show and he offered
well actually no I think at first did he
hold on quick clarifying question did he
delete those
messages in before he announced this
video I don't I'm I don't know Pro I
because I you went to go look for the
messages after this happened and they
were gone correct it may have happened
when you texted him that thing and he's
like oh he's not on my team yeah
but yeah I know he uh he offered to take
pictures of me at the crater clash and I
said Thank I appreciate the offer but
I'm going be really busy this and that
and then uh I met him in the lobby of my
hotel um and he you know he said hi he
was really nice and I seen him a few
other times and then eventually I was
like okay yeah he could take pictures
because Teddy fresh made the robe and uh
I didn't have any professional photos in
it so yeah he took photos and then uh
actually I believe that's when he told
me that he was the guy that called in
and I connected it but uh yeah he took
the photos and I didn't end up even
posting them uh nothing nothing wrong
with him they were great photos but uh
Lena posted something and tagged him and
it he said if you could just if you
could post it and tag I appreciate it I
mean's so here it is and by the way I
mean I like the the composition I love
you guys the photo's not that good yeah
it's a little grainy right AB I
mean it's
okay yeah it I didn't post it
there's
a but I mean it's nice I mean you guys
are awesome so that makes the picture
great yeah go ahead um yeah
um again I wish you didn't delete
everything so I can remember the flow of
things but he kept asking me to collab
with him over and over and I explained
to him I don't do collabs you know it's
nothing against him I just don't do it
because I don't want anyone thinking
that I'm using the show to to do all
these collabs and also like I just did
the creator Clash I've had a lot of
creators who offer you know idbs for
example you know that I could have done
a videos with and I wasn't looking to do
anything like that but he kept asking
and he was very persistent and
eventually I just I he's like it won't
take long it's just real quick 20
minutes whatever it was and again if he
still has the messages he'll be like no
I said it was going to take 30 minutes
whatever the he's going to explain
I don't I don't know exactly how the
flow of things were because of that but
I eventually said yeah he did not have a
lot of followers I was just doing it as
a favor and this is my fear this is why
I did not want to do this you know um
because I was always afraid whatever I
do someone's going to use it someday to
uh you know talk about the show or
whatever it is so yeah this is why no
one asked me again please well
hold on how did he find you at the hotel
that was the part I found oh yeah no I
it the first crater Clash because it was
a new thing um we didn't have all the
security there that we should have and
so fans and were finding out where we
were staying and like waiting there all
night in the lobby just for people to
walk by and he was one of the people
that I saw there um I don't he I'm
guessing he just found out that's where
it was or maybe he got a a
badge you know a badge like a a
photography badge maybe he knew someone
else I know I know he knows some other
YouTubers probably the same he did
with us where he said oh I'm friends
with this person um like he when he
reached out to me he's like oh I
actually I believe you're going to show
the messages but he at one point was
like oh you just head on Curtis Conor
who's a friend of mine so you need to
come on my channel and he just made it
seem like he's really close with all
these guys I don't know if he is or not
but yeah probably says it about us Jake
do little this is um him spamming your
Twitch chat yeah so he you can't delete
twitch chat messes so I was able to look
him up cuz yeah I would so what he would
do also is he would donate like so that
I had you know kind of more forc me to
respond yeah when he would send messages
so kept saying Come on my channel um
where's
the when I click
this I'm trying to find the didn't you
send me a bunch of DMS you guys had
anyway on Twitch he goes dear
AB come on my YouTube Channel please I
will not be
ignored one day my ass my tip didn't
show up on stream but I did send a bribe
it's a little weird tone it's a lot hi
King hope you're good ab aad is King
make video with me
okay
um I don't have a a link to the uh let
me look for it I can make here but
anyway as you look for that here's the
collab you guys made just a show hi
sisters today I'm doing a video with my
pal AB hello how's it going you know
it's going great man I'm so happy to
have you here I wanted he's even wearing
he's wearing a freaking Teddy fresh
shirt mhm and even though I did do it
that was my one terms that he did not
mention age3 or anything like that
but uh he's wearing the Smokey shirt so
it's like this this Fallen fan
phenomenon dude it's like you can't just
move on with your life you have to like
if you stop watching the show you have
to for some reason hate
everything about me I
Fallen um but anyway I thought it was
really nice today I'm doing a video with
my pal AB hello how's it going you know
it's going great man I'm so happy to
have you here I've wanted to do a video
with you for a while I'm new to doing
this whole YouTube collab type thing
that's what you would call it but yeah
I'm I'm honored thank you for having me
we met and I took photos for you but M
sweet boy
APS good boy good kid boing
um are those uh messages worth reading
AB probably I think they are right it's
been so long I'm trying to I'm going
through our WhatsApp because I sent him
before break um I'm not going to read
it but if you want to move forward it
kind of goes in line with stuff he sent
to other people so so anyway he's trying
to reach out to AB but then we started
to slowly realize that he's been
reaching out to everybody here he's
messaging
Sam okay YouTuber LOL do you do digital
art I
do are you open to commissions at all I
have a clothing brand and fund for
people with chronic
illness I love some stuff for bro okay
you going to accuse me of profiting from
me
from never stop. L do you think that's
appropriate to do a lol after talking
about chronic illness I mean how
insensitive can you be there's nothing
funny there's nothing funny about is
LOL so
weird Sam says I didn't do commissions
at the moment because I'm too busy but
can you let me know what you had in mind
and I can see if I can fit it in let me
get my thoughts together a bit more and
I'll let you know also be at the live
show excited to see you there awesome
see you there let me blah blah blah show
was amazing
yesterday yeeha I'm going to come out to
LA soon this year so again
he's he's a fan he's working the angle
on on Sam it's also working the angle on
Olivia Dan and love
separately here's
this Jake do
little come on my Channel please who's
this to this was to me so he this okay
come on my Channel please this is me
reminding you to come on my
channel uh excuse me are you doing
videos with people now um girl I love
did you leave keep him on red uh I
didn't accept it I you're such a legend
love that a lot of these um the crew
didn't even see them until the situation
went I was looked I'm I'm piss
guy didn't even message me he didn't
message me dude the Jake I
thought we're boys man he didn't message
me although I went and checked I think
if he erases it yeah you're right I
think do you remember when uh I think
Tana went back last year at one point
when the Adam Lavine stuff was happening
and she said that if it says accept but
there's no message it means that they
had sent one and it showed up like that
for you oh it did yeah okay so I don't
know what he sent me I don't got
dude sorry Zach I think he knew you're
just too cool that he wasn't going to
get in Jake my
boy he wasn't ready for l no BR all
right so that's what he did to
Olivia
this is to love is this to you love oh
yeah love I'll be at Creator clash with
media pass shooting content for my
channel I would love to shoot content
for the Pod if interested I have called
in before and would love to work
together again again I'm a friend of the
show yeah there's no again we didn't
work that just we didn't work together
yeah just to be clear you called
in and we talked for a minute that's not
working
together um
Dan I'll be at the creative clash with
the media pass same message copy pasted
message dude disrespectful that is
disrespectful come
on so wait what okay so your DMs are
here number six yeah and
number okay perfect so here's all the
the messages to AB there well he deleted
some so they might not make complete
sense but you get the vibe based on what
I said says okay buddy good luck let me
see what I can do for you so he asked
for tickets yeah M or this or some kind
of path for create a class to take
photos hey dude I'm did you hook them up
were you able to oh no no I'm sorry this
I'm sorry this one is for our live show
okay oh oh wait wait wait no I'm sorry
okay yeah first one was about the fight
he deleted whatever then the next one
hey dude I'm trying to get you a spot he
was trying to get tickets to our live
yes and did you hook him up for that we
did we have a long waiting list but the
tricky part is we usually don't know how
many spots we have until the day I've
set AB I'm keeping an eye out though
I'll update you if anything changes so
nice Okay that's totally okay buddy hey
buddy any
updates uh I got you a ticket blah blah
blah yada yada Bob's your uncle M
okay um
so this man is a he's a fan of the show
I think it's important to set that he
knows me he knows the show falling all
right so that with all that being said
let's just let's watch the video and you
you guys are going to enjoy this because
I'm telling you I couldn't get through
oh wait I need the backup he removed
it he literally just removed it when I
just opened it yeah that's crazy he's
watching I guess he's watching bro why
did you wait till this moment like come
on if you did it yesterday I would have
sued nah be real not yesterday be real
dude come on maybe two days
ago two days ago I I believe you thank
you um we need the uh backup y I'm
looking for right now he's getting the
back up can I just say uh now too just
because he is whining about people
harassing him and stuff
don't he he's getting it he's he's
getting it real bad today here on the
show the embarrassment is is plenty we
don't we don't all of you in the
audience you don't need to interact with
him this is enough please just
embarrassing yeah I totally agree agree
but yeah and another thing I guess I
wanted to touch on
is I feel
like first of all death threats are
horrible and should never happen
obviously I've got them it's scary and
it's
unsettling that being said I do feel
like some when people get caught doing
something and then go I'm getting death
threats like they I feel like it's a
little overplayed here you know what I
mean you and everybody
else oh you think that too yeah I mean
you're a public figure you're going to
get psycho I mean is has anyone here on
the crew not gotten a death threat at
one point that that's my other thing too
it's like yeah dude we you know we
Diamond doesn't you know what I mean not
saying it's okay people that do that are
nuts and them but it's also like
that doesn't absolve you of anything
because that happened to you and again I
didn't even say anything he goes please
make it stop oh you know what it was he
saw me talking about it right now and I
said the video's still up on your
channel so he maybe he
thinks now he's done everything he
can all right here we go guys ready
let's to do this Ethan Klein harmful or
hypochondria let's go before this video
starts I would like to preface it with
a
oh full screen is a little too okay all
right come on few things leading up to
this video I was a huge fan of the H3
podcast when I was at my sickest so
leading up to this he was a huge fan
right the minute I brushed across
something he cares about a little bit
brushed upon it now he's he's done alls
are off I'm exposing him too far the
podcast was always something that I
could watch to make me feel less alone I
even remember saving up money from my
first job ever to buy multiple Teddy
fresh items more recently I was on the
podcast speaking to Ethan about an
unrelated subject I left VidCon to
attend their most recent live show and I
am also friendly with a few of their
crew members but I saw a few very
concerning things when it comes to Ethan
Klein's lupus journey and as someone
who's been sick his entire life I felt
like I needed to make this video not
only have I dealt with chronic illness
but I run a nonprofit where I support
people financially who are sick and
struggling okay dude like whatever I
probably gave more money during this
whole thing than you have I mean that
doesn't take he's legitimately doing
that that's my point right you're right
it's Petty my point is though that he's
saying I stole money yeah right which
yeah I mean the the core of the
accusation is nonsense I mean the work
he's doing is good as a viewer but um of
the podcast if I were to stand back and
watch Ethan lie saying certain things
about li like I feel like this is
genuinely I think this might be
defamation M to say lying about an
illness to make money I think that might
be actual might be he would have to know
that it's not true and I but he does
he's such a fan of the
show as one of your haters who was watch
there's Parts where he omits certain
pieces where I'm making it clear right
go ahead D sorry no no it's fine I was
going to say as I was watching one of
your haters react to this and as they
said it's completely different if you
said I have this disease I need money
and which you did not do they were
defending you it's completely different
well you guys will see when he gets to
that part he I think he includes all
donations we
got just period but let's see his health
that are just straight up misinformation
then i' would be doing a disservice to
an entire Community my goal in making
this video is not to do anything but
address what I've seen from Ethan and
his behavior Ethan Klein claimed to have
Lupus made money off of it and then
admitted that he made everything up and
self diagnosed himself okay that's
up things say and you know what
dude for you to sit there and say to say
it like that is so far from actual
reality dude it's just me yeah and
frankly I felt like during that whole
journey I was I was being really
vulnerable I was opening up my met every
medical detail and because I I genuinely
was going through a medical issue people
that watch the show know I saw a
hematologist I saw a rheumatologist I
went to my my uh regular doctor I was
doing blood tests like every week for
months MH and I'm still I'm still
getting checked up by the way I don't
know if you know this Jake maybe you can
tell me if this if this is okay or not
but I did a a stool sample I in a
bucket bro and they found some
elevated thing for autoimmune so I have
to go back I think in a week or two to
do another test and if it is
positive Jake they have to do a
colonoscopy to see if I have irritable
bowel disease is that okay Jake you
you how dare you how dare
you how dare you come on man as I'm
recording this yesterday I posted a
teaser to this video and I've received
more backlash than I've gotten in a very
long time so much so that's again the
his reaction is it's not me it's them
right I mean maybe I wonder why I don't
know sometimes there's obvious haters
but if you read the comments most of the
people were just trying to be like no
you don't understand the this is what
actually happened and providing lots of
information yeah the feedback on that
teaser post wasn't like oh you for
coming after Ethan it it was like right
they were they were being fairly
charitable that this must be some kind
of misunderstanding mhm at least the top
ones that I that I saw were maybe there
was some more vicious hate in
there yeah so bro like hold on and I'm
trying to see if he left up that
reel looks like he removed that to but
this was all up to today everything was
up
delete somebody from the H3 crew direct
messaged me and called me insane for
thinking this I also want it to be known
that I understand the other side not
true I me dramatic I mean yeah he said
that's
crazy right that's insane he wasn't like
dude you're insane you're mentally ill
dude right like that's if it wasn't work
related trust me I would want to say a
lot more than that but yeah love you
buddy love you
too side of things I get that dealing
with health problems can be a very scary
time in someone's life but when the
health problems that Ethan Klein is
talking about are completely
self-diagnosed with zero symptoms you
have how can you say that why that's so
many that's just factually not true and
yeah you had symptoms why were you
getting help I still have a rash on my
face yeah just watch all of the episodes
from last year Ean is like I look like a
raccoon my eyes are all like we're like
less than a minute into this and it's
that's what I was saying that's what
happened to us we didn't make it past
two minutes like we couldn't already
it's wrong about everything oh I'm being
told this is actual how can I assume
it's anything but bad faith because the
whole context of everything I'm talking
about is going over the
medical uh tests that were ordered by my
doctors like the whole context is in
that it's your show and you share
everything about yourself so you're
going through this journey of figuring
out what's going on and you're
organically talking about your life like
it's not anything more than that and by
the way there's tons of people like I
have Lupus and it's nice to see people
talking openly about this but somehow I
guess Jake thinks I was attacking
everyone with Lop stealing lupus Glory
yeah I said no pickles what a weird
thing man you have to ask
yourself why is he doing this what
that's what I ask about you why that's
what I have been asking myself about you
why have you done this and why have you
left it up this whole time like why we I
didn't you know it didn't have to be
like this I think the upbeat music's a
nice CH touch so good job yeah all right
how it all started let's see can I give
you real quick yeah I just want to say
this before I forget because I'm
guessing this is exactly how it's going
to play out he posted that story
yesterday so that when we do react to it
now he's going to make his followup I
even I even I I said this he still
talked about it and then I privated it
and he still talked about it bro you
literally you Pro said I'm lying about a
chronic illness knowingly to make money
yeah yeah you expect me I have every
right in the world as does
anyone accused of such things to defend
my myself and you're a fool for
thinking anything else
yes all right how it all started on June
16th 2023 Ethan live streamed an episode
of his show the H3 podcast the episode
was going fine until Ethan said
something unexpected this morning it was
going fine until Ethan started opening
up being vulnerable about his his scary
medical issu lying mhm by the way that
morning I was
legit really anxious and that's why I
brought it up because I was like I'm I
have to be true to myself and talk about
this cuz it's so much on my mind and I
want to share it mhm I thought I had
cancer for sure I'm not going to lie
this morning what happened this morning
I got some cuz I did a bunch I had weird
blood values when I did my I just did
the whole blood work to test my
cholesterol and stuff was fine my white
blood cells and platelet counts were
high so my doctor was like it's probably
it's probably nothing but I can send you
to a hematologist well I wasn't super
worried but then I went to the
hematologist and we did a whole bunch of
tests that was you know earlier this
week and they started coming in and so
like this man literally said I did it
without any doctors but what the
you self diagnosed with no symptoms
you're you're showing me talking about
talking to a hematologist like here's
one tripe taste a lot of this stuff has
to do with like leukemia oh saying that
an elevated tripe taste relates now he's
a doctor after making fun after
on me for self diagnosing as he
says now this dude is going to come here
and preach to me about what these
medical things mean and by the way where
did you learn these medical school no
you learned them on Google you
hypocrite loser you Googled them that's
right I am unless you went to medical
school and I don't know about it listen
I did I did Premed for about 7 years
that's almost twice as much as it should
take you I know my I I'll fact
check so move forward this is a super SC
yeah I know thanks bro so far everything
you're right thanks bro thanks well
let's see try Tri tmia is like saying
that sneezing relates to sinus cancer
Ethan it is so not like that like this
is a serious blood marker what are you
talking about I'm talking to a
hematologist what are your
qualifications you child why are
you telling me
this from what point are you here to
tell me this
what the then states that he went
to check on his cholesterol levels and
then seemingly read his own lab results
why are you saying it like that he's
saying it like he knows you're lying why
are you saying it like that I said in
the video he showed I talked to my
doctor why is it like he seemingly
talked to a doctor and he allegedly read
this and it's like what what he saw a
doctor and he's reading the results
every possible turn and chance he P
paints me in the most bad faith yeah and
crazy
listen you know my policy on this
like I I dress it head
on and this is probably one of the most
up things anyone's accused me of
and there's been a
lot I clearly said in the clip you
showed I talked to my doctor he
recommended if I wanted to see
hematologist I could I went to the
hematologist that showed other elevated
uh attributes and self- diagnosed
himself based off of Google searches
you didn't even show that
did not happen God what did not happen
where where did that happen what is
wrong with you you idiot
dude
God I think that this dude should I
think he should retire this yeah I I
hate to tell someone don't pursue their
dreams but this is such a miss
don't pursue your dreams insane I would
never
I would never say that don't pursue your
dreams go to sleep on your dreams it's
time it's time to find a new career path
I I think this is this is your last
video go go to med school I mean has a
passion thank you please be a doctor go
follow your passion because at least
never stop Ean here never claimed to be
a doctor because you'll see he goes on
contr quite the contrary more recent
test result that came in this test is
the one that Ethan runs with throughout
this entire Journey my Anna tier this is
um also like leukemia and lupus and
first Anna titer makes no sense the part
that Ethan calls Anna stands for
anti-nuclear antibodies it's an act you
Googled that you God of
course you just Googled that excuse me
nerd this is not dor this is not a
medical school podcast this is a person
reading his results a person who did
I've ever heard that in my life you
never claim to know exactly what it is
or how to say it or what it stands for
like what the hell also you watch the
show my dude yes have you do you know
Ethan he says everything wrong Ethan is
on GP day and cannot pronounce GPT yes I
don't believe this guy is a fan I don't
no he is he not GP up you don't think he
watches the show I watch the show this
guy does not watch is he a fake fan
because like he called Falls in he wears
the merch he's reached out to everybody
Fallen he's just trying to get a job
yeah maybe maybe maybe in the weirdest
way
possible bro by the way bro it's not
happening you know there's I'm not
hiring you yeah damn just to be
clear go ahead on that note you know all
the like I don't I do not get why so
many people try to capitalize off
talking about you I mean it works
for some people but ignoring me getting
the job that's how initially you even
heard about me was defending you even
today you were talking about a fan who
put out a nice video and you gave him
you gave him praise and you and you
pended in the comments like I don't like
these people don't see you as a person
I've always felt this way they see you
like I don't know if it's cuz you have
money or F or whatever it is they think
you don't have feelings you don't have
nothing and they want to attack you for
absolutely anything but this is by far
the biggest miss I've ever seen
it is love up there and as a listener I
love the whole lupus Saga it was such a
funny Arc and the for me the best part
at the end was when you guys are just
like going on an online quiz and the
only thing you qualify for is the age
and we're like that's it you have it
it's like okay like I don't know maybe
he just doesn't have a sense of humor is
that a condition might yeah I mean might
be
um yeah I mean if if I if I was to
diagnose him he's got chronic unfun
that's why you need to retire bro it's
been a short career and let's just make
keep it short wrap it up wrap it up
um yes acronym that Ethan pronounces
Anna instead of Ana like most every
Medical Professional does mother Ethan
is not a medical professional you're
saying it's because I didn't say it
correctly I'm I'm lying about it like I
had never heard that phrase yeah now I
know it's Ana I'm not a doctor
and this this this acting like he has
all this innate medical knowledge like
bro you did this on Google
too
this also adds to my claim of
Ethan searching his labs and not hearing
the results from an actual doctor due to
the mispronunciation I even due to the
Mison that is the most unprofessional
way to deduct a conclusion from a
situation so because you couldn't say it
right you didn't see actually see a
doctor that's insane well and the truth
is Jake um most of my correspondents
which I read on the show were with my
doctors so they wrote it out to me okay
and I read I think I read all of my
doctor message or at least most of them
I think also reading something not
correctly is a condition so I have
dyslexia are you like aware of that one
definitely ableism no I'm just kidding
no I mean he's trying to go super woke
right it's like woke gone wrong and uh
um and and he now he's making fun of me
for being
dyslexic like what what's
up according to the Mayo Clinic in most
cases a positive Ana test indicates that
you're the Mayo Clinic what did you go
did you Google that you
really getting your information from
Mayo Clinic he's like according to Wiki
how exactly immune system has launched a
misdirected attack on your own tissue in
other words an autoimmune reaction
meaning this could have been from
anything you like mayna including asthma
allergies the common cold or even eczema
keep eczema in mind throughout this
video oh he's setting up a big dunk I
feel it I talk that great link to my
doctor's an elevated Ana is is
Meaningful in fact I think one of my I
think the doctor said I read it I don't
remember but no my doctor said it 15% of
people with Ana it's elevated and they
don't know why they're not sick but
they're totally fine but people with
chronic elevated Ana tests generally the
other 85 have an autoimmune issue it can
be elevated for when you get sick and
stuff as I understand it but it goes
back down so I need to they said to get
a meaningful test I have to wait like a
year for to to see if it goes down or
Not Right But I don't know I love Dr D
he's Dr D right at MD you
know I'm a doctor kind
Works my levels are insane and
the note says hom homogeneous and
speckled exclamation homogeneous and
speckled is you're going to
tell me what's hom homogeneous and
speckled you dare
it how dare you how dare you gatekeep
illness how dare you this dude doesn't
even have Lupus by the
way he's got lupus Glory he's stealing
all the lupus Glory right there's enough
lupus glory in town for both of us
buddy I didn't know Fallen fans actually
physically fall and hit their head
Oh's go nice got him let's go right
let's go got him go right
now he's going to make a video now about
how he never hit his head and you made
that up right right and I can continues
to lie about
me
an interesting finding but this doesn't
mean anything more than a lab result in
doing again my result was like 1 to 320
which is a significant positive
result scumbag I'll take your word for
it cuz I'm not a
doctor unlike you he is research yes
homogeneous ins speckled can mean a
specific type of Lupus but there have
also been many Ana test results that
come back homogeneous and speckled where
the diagnosis turned out to be eczema
huh thanks do you loser
how dare you sit down and film this how
dare you I'm having a serious medical
thing and I have probably have to get a
colonoscopy and I probably do have some
kind of autoimmune disease and you
scumbag are sitting here calling me a
liar for what dude why again why did he
do this I just it's befuddling it's
bedazzling my mind is bedazzled yeah
well I'll I'll I'll tell you just so you
get worried I wrote the doctor this
morning I was like I'm super stressed
out like what's what's going on with
these and he just wrote me back and it
makes me feel a little better and
actually this morning I had a
conversation with Chad chpt that made me
feel a little better too conversation by
the way said and Jess I said that
knowing that it's silly mhm and we all
laugh I did I said youo Doctor it
doesn't seem like good results on the
tri taste test I'm stressing about it
and he said it's not a very high
elevation I wouldn't not be stressed
about it still waiting for the molecular
studies Chad Chi was like it's probably
not leukemia oh good it could be lupus
but I don't have enough reaching out to
your doctor aftering at lab results is
exactly what they're there for and the
doctor said that there was nothing to
worry about no he said we have to wait
for more results brother yeah I
don't think you dumb you silly
dumb wow you shared exactly what
the doctor said and you were very
transparent what a liar 100% transparent
about everything what a liar you know
who said it was probably not a big deal
chat GPT maybe he's getting a little
yeah you should crisscross there
yeah um yeah my doctor never said that
dummy why else would he send me to a
hematologist to do tests why for fun the
milk in you medical industrial
complex charging that
insurance fair enough these guys are
pretty busy I feel like though I don't
think they're looking for um I'm just
they're hurting I I know you they're not
hurting for clients in case D's working
on his response video
already according to Ethan chat GPT made
him feel better saying it's not leukemia
but it could still be lupus I put this
to the test when talking to chat GPT
with the same lab results the chatbot
consistently says talk to your doctor
and basically don't take anything it's
saying as fat you dumb oh my God
you don't you're a Noob at chat
TBT you don't know to use it like me you
you silly dumb here's what I
did that's like the basic way of using
CH even I know that I said let's talk
about a hypothetical patient duh here's
his results blah blah blah blah then you
can have a real conversation about it if
you ask it to like help you with the
diagnosis I know that it will say that
it can't do that you silly dumb goofy
he's probably using 3.5 as well
such a d oh God he probably is using 3
.5 absolutely would it's hard
for me not to get super pissed this and
again it's important to remember he kept
this up all
month till
today kept it up this whole
time okay fact which Ethan had to ignore
to get to this point and from this point
on is when Ethan Klein runs with this
chat GPT lupus diagnosis very quickly
let's talk about what lupus
is boring
cares oh God lus is a chronic autoimmune
disease that can affect crash's
feil physical exam nois oh and just like
Ethan I also forgot to mention it
affects 90% women being two to three
times more prevalent so many times so
many times he's obviously lying this is
a girly disease this is for the girls
only we every time we talked about it we
talked about the it's mostly when L is
like hi girl I see you girl it was also
misogynistic of you to think you have
it women I was doing Glory you
manspreading stealing the lupus Valor
from the girlies oh that's not right
that's not right that's not right no
that's up among africanamerican
Hispanic Latina
Asian-American other Pacific island are
women then among white women with all
that being said now that you know a
little bit about what lupus is let's go
back to someone who admittedly doesn't
know what lupus is I don't even know
what the lupus is oh wow yeah so
you said it Checkmate what a liar here I
am being super transparent and upfront
about everything lupus uh symptoms I
wasn't really I'll take lupus over
uh cancer lupus symptoms
includes um muscle and joint pain no
fever no rashes sometimes they get on my
face but it's got gone for a while chest
pain no hair loss I mean look at me sun
or light sensitivity no kidney problems
mouth sores prolonged or extreme fatigue
anemia I don't have anemia in the blood
test memory problems weird have no
symptoms wow cuz so chat TBD is like
because you have no symptoms like
leukemia and lupus usually are
accompanied with symptoms then it's hard
for me to say what could it be that's
crazy Ela that's a phenomenal question
to ask don't talk to
me
right this dumb idiot masquerading as a
medical professional while criticizing
me for the same thing if you know
anything about lupus dummy the one thing
that I've heard over and over again
through this journey from people with
lupus is that it takes a really long
time to get a diagnosis because it's a
strange illness it manifests in all
kinds of different ways and it's
extremely difficult to get that
diagnosis most people it takes them
years and years to get the official
lupus diagnosis you scumbag
loser I hate him right it is I do
it's just so mean and yeah I guess I
know bro it's more personal for you
because it's about you I guess to me
it's just like it's so utterly
embarrassing in like a funny way but for
you like yeah I mean this is your life
and you you are ill with something and
you're trying to figure it out and it's
like an open book ex you can see he says
everything he says I don't know what
lupus is I don't even have the symptoms
I'm just nervous about this thing that's
happening it's like it's crazy
I wasn't like I'm so sck can I get
donations please
right oh my God the thing is like you
put this out at 125,000 views it wasn't
all hate you had like five or 10,000
likes so there is people on the internet
that watched this video and
believed what you said in your so-called
apology you said I apologize to everyone
what who are you apologizing to and for
what dummy I can teach you how to make a
good apology I'm the best 10 out of 10
oh my God
man ask what could it be with most lupus
diagnoses being based off of symptoms
and according to Ethan he has none
whatsoever you would think this would be
the end of the AI lupus diagnosis but
boy is that wrong I have a rash and
chronic fatigue yeah yeah I still have
the rash and I feel like super fatigue
honestly especially over like this last
weekend I felt like it can't be normal
to feel like this
energyless like it's just so hard to
will myself to stand up and do
anything um cuz at first it was like my
blood platelets were super high and my
white blood cells were super high and
that means one of those not super high I
guess but it was above the normal and my
original general doctor was like it
could be that you just have high values
on that and it's fine you can see my
platelets are pretty high 530 a certain
type of w white blood cell is just a
little bit High just a little bit over
the norm get down to the trip this one
stressed me out cuz it's almost double
the normal range hopefully the doctors
are listening the an titer one me
up it says the normal I love how he says
you're doing this for Content like this
is this is exhilarating content right
here going through your lab results one
by
one me 1 to 40 and 1 to 80 minus 1 to
320 the lab that did this they wrote an
exclamation in red after this so
did he give you a reasoning why or not
yet he says he's he says it's not a very
high elevation I would not be stressed
about it still waiting for the molecular
studies so I guess there's more test
results he's still waiting on but the
good news is my cholesterol is fine if I
don't die of cancer before uh I have a
heart attack so the weird thing about
this is that I did a blood test a year
ago mhm and my platelets and white blood
cells were elevated back then too Ethan
is being a little bit hypochondria are
you kidding dude no this isn't
hypochondriac and by the way I know
people say oh he's a hypochondriac
listen I admit that sometimes having
medical anxiety I do not think this is
hypochondria I I'm almost certain that I
have some kind of autoimmune thing going
on again my mom has autoimmune disease
it's it's scary I had one one time I me
I don't if I mentioned on the show but I
had elevated blood test I forget exactly
what it was but it scared the out
of me for a long time it really
me up well I think you're a loser for
thinking that yeah why are you lying to
yourself me why you lying yeah yeah it's
scary it is scary mhm I'm glad you're
okay thank you stop it according to
Ethan in the past he has had lab results
where his white blood cell count was
elevated which I believe is connected to
his gird diagnosis because well okay
Doctor my God who cares what you believe
do how the who are you you're
gatekeeping medical saying don't
diagnose yourself and you're sitting
here pretending to be a doctor I
have asked my doctors that question you
dumb and every time they go there
they wouldn't be related you scumbag you
you loser stop making YouTube
videos
forever
stop get up off the couch leave the room
and never come back
please just turn the camera off forever
bury your
camera let's have a funeral for the
camera and the microphone let's just
let's go back we'll all get in a
semicircle we'll say some nice words for
the YouTube short YouTube career you had
and let's bury it and move on to
something else maybe medical school I
think that's good I think I think that
would be good for everybody H be Dr D
little yes I mean that's iconic said no
pickles that is kind of Icon yeah you
were born for this you would
be that's so good can't can't do
this
yeah well medical school is hard and he
doesn't seem very bright no offense all
offense full offense yeah I mean this
dude basically invited the my like I I
can say pretty much anything I want
about you dummy after you accuse
me of this loser boy later in this
video his doctor says it is also saying
that you're not a hypochondriac and then
following it up with this is wild well
the good news is if I do have cancer cuz
I was not I'm not symptomatic at all so
if I do we caught it I guess as earlier
than I would have if I started having
symptoms you know what I mean absolutely
but I don't I I think this this idea of
cancer seems unlikely based on what chat
BT told me and uh the doctor told me not
to worry so I'm trusting him on that one
but if you look up all the ones I'm
abnormal for it all is like you have
leukemia or lupus I'll take lupus any
day bro hit me with that lupus hit me
with that lupus okay I'm being so silly
in this
obviously the premise of choosing one
illness over another is silly and absurd
but go ahead and explain why jokes
aren't funny is not only undermines
people who have Lupus you know
undermines people you is sitting
there pretending to be a doctor
gatekeeping lupus you don't even have
Lupus who the are
you his experiences but also makes it
seem like a lupus diagnosis is an easy
thing to come by also he just said the
idea of cancer seems unlikely based on
what chat GPT told him but he follows up
by saying according to chat GPT he has
leukemia or lupus this idea of cancer
seems unlikely based on what chat BT
told me but if you look up all the ones
I'm abnormal for it all is like you have
leuk someone it also suggested Shen
syndrome the Chach BT suggested that I
don't know what the that is these
chronic illnesses like shogren syndrome
that Ethan keeps thinking he has are
predominantly in women which he fails to
mention multiple times men have it dumb
just because it's predominantly
women does men get it you just said it
men get these
diseases it's such an idiotic thing to
say like how could you utter that and
not stop
yourself well it's mostly women to get
lupus so I don't even know why you would
even lie about
it
what according to John's Hopkins most
people who are diagnosed with SH
syndrome are 40 I didn't say I had that
I said it seems like I don't have
that an older and women are as much
as 10 times more likely to develop it
than men I'm not saying it's impossible
to be diagnosed with it as a man but you
would think that if Ethan did any amount
of research or spoke to a doctor instead
of catp his worries would be lessened
also holy dude it's were you not
listening he was reading a message from
the doctor that's the weird part about
it is like are you listening to your own
video
this this is Fallen
fitis it's a me it's a brain
disease zero symptoms his likelihood of
having any of these things is so much
smaller oh God my boyfriend pass being
diagnosed he's lying he just keeps
saying that it doesn't make it true you
did have symptoms that's why you got
checked out at the doctor yeah he's just
lying okay I mean he even says at one
point did hundreds of hours of research
like okay good so then you know you're
alive what were you watching
dude he's watching I think he was
watching the Christian one the H3
podcast you know the Christian gr yeah
he was watching the wrong
show wonder what those guys are up to
good old oh yeah don't say that M block
her I'm sorry to hear that mute her
please I'm sorry to hear that what the
hell I'm sorry Sarah I didn't know it
was that serious yeah I'm telling you
it's serious cuz well when I read about
lupus it said like I guess like 90% of
the people survive which is oops not I
know great but it's not cancer it's not
cancer yeah and it's treatable says
people who get it who get it treated can
live a normal like lifespan I mean yeah
lupus is treatable in some situations
yes and Ethan's wealth would make the
process much easier but okay so I have
money rich
got you dude
of course he do I believe
he doesn't mention at all during this
video that throughout this whole thing I
was donating a lot of money to people
for their medical bills specifically
because I was like I feel bad because
this stuff is expensive and it's not
prohibitive to me where it would be to a
lot of people and therefore that's why
I'm giving money away he omitted all of
that yeah yeah
interesting but somebody donated and
said that their boyfriend died shortly
after a lupus diagnosis and instead of
empathizing Ethan spews out more chat
GPT info he's received and says people
who get it treated can live a normal
lifespan getting into the mother
idiot why didn't you just break down
crying for the rest of the episode what
part of what I said still is not true
[Music]
okay this is the worst video on you
well it's not on YouTube anymore yeah
right it is now on our channel right
true live on forever live on forever
yeah this is the worst takedown video
ever I mean dude shame on you and you
had so many chances to not do this the
preview AB from us saying dude this is
not going to be work out good for you
trust us
yep next episode that Ethan talks about
his health and left it up all month zero
Sy we get a few updates on what could be
going on so I have two doctors I've got
my general doctor and my hematologist
now and I've been messaging them both
panicking so let's see who got back to
me I mean my I'm so what is not
wrong with me okay now he says regarding
the labs the Ana is something
interesting take this with a grain of
salt with all the patient symptoms
before interpreting going acknowledge
that you said it correctly that time
since he made such a big deal about it
no is this his edit or is that
Ian uh that's that's Ian that's prob
ISS some of dises by the way
acknowledging the silliness exactly in
our podcast clip that he's
showing that's why I'm saying this guy's
not a fan maybe you're right maybe he
had us all
fooled he did say he did hundreds of
hours of research he was trying to be
like the girl on Salt Lake he was trying
to work his way in here but it didn't
work out so this is the backup plan you
might be right about that yeah you pick
up a Teddy fresh shirt all of a sudden
what I'm supposed to buy it no we caught
you a and a like possibly the so fitus
yeah I'm waiting for the hematologist
but he he he made me feel better on
Friday when he messaged me he says uh I
don't think this is a new and separate
problem than the one we discussed oh no
Ethan had already spoken to his doctor
about his Le I'm waiting for the
hematologist and I even said there you
what is wrong with you broes and the
general doctor said that it's most
likely an esophageal issue which Ethan
has had problems with for a long amount
of time but a new diagnosis seems to
almost excite Ethan so much so that he
oh my God you're this dude's so
up he wishes he had
lupus runs with these claims for over a
month after his general doctor said it's
not something more than his prior
diagnosis this is so personal he didn't
say that by the way my doctor did not
say that he's saying like the doctor
told you liter he said you don't have
Lupus he said Ethan Klein you do not
have lupus or autoimmune disease
anything you're fine and I know that for
sure yeah it's so personal that's what I
I don't get about it yeah it's it's like
he he understands your body better than
you do mhm very very
weird he's King he's the king of sick
he's the king of sick no one is sicker
than this man what's the name of his
charity Don't Stop Don't Stop Don't Stop
L don't
stop don't stop LOL little intensive you
think yeah don't stop.
kek give me a break I love my doctor by
the way he's so nice so nice to have a
good doctor who like I just trust his I
trust him that he knows what he's
talking about and he gets back to me wow
it seems like I'm really Hamming it up y
Hamming it up there you trust in the
doctor that says you're probably okay
yep that's what I said but I see a
tissue box on the table right Ethan
claims to trust his doctor and like him
a lot but on the other hand chat GPT is
giving a new exciting diagnosis so I'll
ask you again why is what is he even
talking about this new and exciting
diagnosis I don't know what the
he's talking about maybe it's the next
clip he doing this I don't think it is I
don't think he shows it so now he goes
okay this is where you you up so
bad and if I wanted to sue you I
probably could ruin your whole
life and you're lucky that I'm not
vindictive like C Cav but listen to what
he says here exciting diagn is so I'll
ask you again why is he doing this why
is he doing this cut donations and
empathy you know you
scumbag you
loser these title cards and the sounds
and the music I mean sound look a little
familiar they remind me of uh goar's
video yeah I mean that's what I think he
just wanted the H3 hate Market is huge
yeah there's like nobody outside this
community that likes me like nobody left
we have pushed everybody away yeah you
guys watching are the only ones that
like me most most of you even some of
you area right it's like you know it's
easy it's good it's a good milk oh now I
must defend Ethan Klein it is one of the
most difficult things I have to do even
my ha saying that it's got to say
something though that after all these
years online these are the videos being
posted like this is the worst they have
to make up like this about you it
is I feel like I feel like we've been
good I've been a good boy I say some
dumb offensive stuff but like I've never
scamming people I'm never taking shitty
ads I'm never doing anything under
illegal or Shady I'm not fans
I'm not doing any of that I come
here I do the show I go home to my wife
and kids and that's my whole
life yeah like what more do you want
yall talk about how degenerate all these
creators are I'm living the American
dream baby that Trad dream
that's right you're a TR cath
herole
pie in July that's
America that's
America oh all right thank you we got we
have to move cuz it's going to take me a
while to get through this another
B during the initial stream where Ethan
talks about his health problems he
received
$1,550 42 in donations these were either
relating to his health or gifted
memberships this is I think he's
counting all donations in that episode
yeah I don't know what we get per
episode but he'll show you he has a
spreadsheet okay good during the time
where he expressed his medical anxieties
some of those donations gave better
advice than chat GPT did but Ethan
seemed to ignore them they included
things like Ethan don't look too closely
at your Labs I'm a nurse and they're
often slightly low or elevated based on
different factors an exclamation mark
just means abnormal but two exclamation
marks means critical or don't look too
much into it wait for the doctor please
and I'm a nurse and the context of your
overall health is so important to
understanding Labs I know it's hard try
to be patient and trust that your md
will evaluate the full picture sometimes
things will be elevated at Baseline some
of these donations were even from people
struggling with lupus or other illnesses
telling Ethan not to worry about his
Labs sorry this dude is like such a
he's treating people with loop as
like
these also these weren't like solicited
like what is the point being made here
that I did this that you were like
asking for people to give you medical
advice via Super Chat he even said we
didn't read them right like we didn't
encourage reading them right he said
that I mean reading them would encourage
more if we read every Super Chat it
would be the whole episode we we skip a
lot U not that we don't appreciate it
and you're right if I read super chats
more people would dude I during this
whole thing I was like charge that
back thank you for the super chat but
charge that back
please you really wanted that extra
thousand that's what he's saying you
needed a thousand that's so stupid after
YouTube's caught after taxes yeah that's
like 200 bucks way more like
that he talks about how rich I am but on
the other hand I'm desperate for $1,000
right that I'm willing
to ruin my entire credibility my all
like you know all
this my wonderful reputation well
respected by
everybody I just wanted to jump in here
for a little bit because people online
are saying that nobody with lupus or
chronic illness actually donated to
Ethan thinking that he was actually sick
I wanted to read all of them I went
through th who was saying that the video
is not even
out is that while the clip was out on
instam it must have been from the previe
thing yeah okay so he's getting ahead of
it go ahead thousands of donations over
the two to 3 months that Ethan was doing
this this is just look at this little
freak he made an Exel of all of the
donations we like bro why are you
obsessed about my money this is insane
what portion of them I recorded myself
reading all of the donations from people
who are
chronically be like that's what I that
this is that's my main question for this
whole
video there must be a script or a tool
to do this CU otherwise that's
insane no manually transcribe every
Super Chat that's I get a restraining
order insane he did this
manually I hope he had a tool that
assist with this
please I don't know I think he might
have done this manually minutes long a
spreadsheet $20 on June 16th I had
cancer dude sucked but the science is so
Advanced these days and if you catch it
early chef's kiss $10 June 19th I have
ESOP filic esophagus and a is being made
by this I don't understand what either
yeah the fans donated super chats people
by the you w like explicitly like what
people donate during episodes where I'm
not talking about how sick I am you know
that
right like just say feature yeah it it
does happen feature it happens every
episode actually if you can believe that
somebody in the chat said maybe you
should have hired him this
is
efficient the spreadsheet it's true yeah
maybe he's good at xl's do we need have
a need for an XL wizard I mean sometimes
all right send a resume Jake send send
your new res updated
resume pretty consistent with your
coughing up I would get an upper
endoscopy and if you can get a sleep
study $5 July 25th I just found out I
have stage three kidney disease chronic
illness is tough $10 July 26th took 5
years to get a lupus diagnosis at 20
years old last year such a long so you
know uhhuh these are people who are but
expressing this like a solidarity like
everybody there's lots of people and
they and they enjoy that people are
seeing them that we're talking openly
about it it's a conversation
yeah battle finding a great
rheumatologist is key best wishes to you
$10 August 16th when I was diagnosed
with you obsessed cancer I had an
ultrasound result that was sent to me
with no context or doctor note that
basically said it was probably cancer I
also got the results before my providers
if I were Ethan I would feel terrible
for receiving donations from people who
have a confirmed diagnosis if you were
me you'd be doing the same exact thing I
am cuz you're me dummy that's that's how
it works if you're me you're me got him
wow beeded with facts and logic if
you were me you'd be doing the same
so shame on
you of something I don't but he
continues to do this for months to come
well you've inspired me I'm going to get
a full panel checkup over our uh our
break so I hope all you guys go do it if
you can because uh it's really important
it's so up how I encourage people
to go had a terrible effect on go get a
annual checkup terrible Zach Zach did
you do it uh yeah I'm I'm All Clean good
for
you running clean you're a well
efficient machine that's right a man
that's 100% man machine boy 100%
ashkanazi oh yeah that's right running
on full pure-blooded ashkanazi Full of L
you just go in there it's easy once a
year I mean it's it could save your life
genuinely could save your life
wow wow what a up what a scum
something is wrong with this guy okay
what's he going to say about this I
wonder thankfully we have good health
insurance thank to you you're welcome
yes and uh well hopefully you guys do
too otherwise then I guess you're just
going to have to die broke and
without doctors die die Jesus what are
you s okay bro you can not be serious
holy
do you are you hear them out what is
this trend where like we pretend that
that we don't know what a joke is like
this is not just him this is happening
in the world we don't know what a joke
is we don't we don't know we forgot we
forgot it's
lost dude okay go ahead break that down
me being silly yeah we say you know in
the comedy world we say we're the last
line of
that's what I so true it's so true you
are a warrior that's what I always say
about myself it's really important I am
really important isn't that sound bite
great that's a good one that's from a
recent
episode yeah I think it was with stavos
and stavos actually goofed on him I
think you might be right yeah yeah we're
the last line of defense we're the last
line of defense that's
me saying man Ethan said this after
already hearing about a fans boyfriend
tragically passing after receiving a
lupus diagnos listen buddy leave the
comedy to the professional right there's
a reason people are watching my show
okay also you have a right to be a
little unsettled seeing a Super Chat
that's like this thing that you're
talking about actually ended
horrifically for for my friend listen I
have to make levity because yeah it's a
comedy show we're here to be
entertaining and everyone have a fun
time and sometimes I think that it's
funny and it breaks the attention when
you get this really tragic um message
that you just you be really silly about
it and and and it brings levity to a
horrible situation yeah I'll get you a
book of jokes we can start from the
beginning sure 101 knock knock knock
knock
who's there your career your
career who your career is going down the
Poo
shoot let's go
that's comedy on the
Fly I'm the last line of defense wow
jokes like
that comedy's in good shape for years
now comedy's alive and well
sis this is not the only
time he says something about how having
money gives you more resources for
complicated health problems but later he
takes offense when people accuse him of
being in a better health situation if he
has money you're rich you'll be fine is
that
[Music]
true is that it now we move on to
what what was that
no that was not the evidence was that
the evidence that was an editing error
let's go back let's go back let's go
back something about how having money
gives you more resources for complicated
health problems but later he takes
offense when people accuse him of being
in a better health situation if he has
money you're rich you'll be fine is that
[Music]
true is that it now we move on to the
next
is that it I'll explain to you in
medical terms so you're what we had
what's called rich people lupus Selena
Gomez has this yeah so it's not as bad
didn't she need like a kidney transplant
or something yeah yeah damn it's like
even if you do have Lupus it's not it's
still not as bad
as still
sucks
uh do you need money man I I'll give you
money
I already gave you 500 I'll I'll it just
seems like you're really focused about
money and if you need money I I will
give you money also
and maybe it's not even worth defending
because he he was completely unable to
back up the point that he was trying to
make but you are very outspoken about
being for public health insurance and
wanting everybody to have the sort of
health insurance that you have so like
you you are self aware about the fact
that you have an advantage when it comes
to this because you have good medical
coverage and you you acknowledge that
and wish it for everyone around you so
what what points is he even scoring by
trying to go down this path of like you
have money there like you you know that
you're aware of that and you openly
advocate for fixing that so I'm curious
if he what's the problem to drive a
point home or if it's just like look at
this guy he's he is money and he
complains right
I'm trying where I'm not kidding you he
reads A Fan's Reddit post talking about
how they have cancer and makes it about
himself I saw a post on the subreddit
and I just want to give a shout out real
quick at the top to a fan who was just I
brought it
up okay I brought it up from the
subreddit say send love what do you mean
all right let me see what let me see how
I made it about myself I got to yeah my
heart goes out he says so I've been
watching H3 all my life diagnosed with
cancer LOL is the I get the vibe though
like I get
it that's kind of how I felt on Monday
is that how you felt Monday because I oh
my god dude God you're such a you are
such a
Los and so you cannot say anything no
matter what you say he's got an issue
with it
yeah listen I'm used to people picking
apart everything I say making videos
about
it this is a new for for the
haters it's pretty annoying it's like
dude just let me just let me live baby
let me live just let me
live all right well it's nice to see
that these don't always uh result in
huge success this might be the first
time someone's made a hater video and
didn't just get a million views right
and total adoration from all the Fallen
fans which is which Real Testament to
you Jake quite a fail right right in the
world of of unanimous success you are
the one failure my friend where the bar
is so low yeah oh that's brutal it's
awesome you were diagnosed with nothing
new the only thing the doctor actually
acknowledged was a prior diag by the way
I was talking about the cancer lull like
he's just being silly about a serious
thing which is a concept that he just
cannot grasp for reason yeah know we all
got it yeah no say Ethan has had for a
while he says I don't think this is a
new and separate problem than the one we
discussed that's kind of how I felt on
Monday right and I haven't heard back
from my hematologist so I feel like
that's probably good news he's still
waiting I guess on some test results
that haven't come in okay say if it's
really bad they'll like kind of be in a
hurry to tell you right I yeah but he
he's still waiting by the way this
person's has cancer and I'm making it
all about me I agree I made that joke
when you acknowledged it oh I'm the one
that made that joke oh that's where you
got it
from you didn't even do any work I did
the work for
you holy man moving past this
apparently Ethan asked one of his crew
members to ask their family member who's
in the medical field what they thought
about his lab results and this was their
response did your family member get back
to you yeah he did but he mention my it
because notice how she says you're not
going to like his answer could it be
that she knows that Ethan has his mind
set on a lupus diet that's the joke bro
that's the joke no hold on he's cooking
here let him cook that's that's why it's
[Laughter]
funny because who would want to have
Lupus that's why it's funny that's why
it's a
joke okay diagnosis and this medical
professional doesn't support that claim
I'll just send you the screenshots it's
not good is it it's not good or bad it's
he said it's listen to The Silly music
just framed it very scary but no it's
not no like it oh because I said you're
not going to like it he said it's
basically inconclusive it depends
heavily on the clinical context a lot of
people have positive anas and are
perfectly normal and some providers
don't even order them because there are
so many false
positives and what about the titter what
about the titter the Ana test that Ethan
received is the titter the title part of
Anna titter
that Ethan has been talking about
literally just measures the presence and
amount of antibodies in the blood this
would be like if a doctor said Ethan was
5'6 and Ethan questioned the doctor's
tool of measurement but no it's not I
literally
what it's not like that at all man I me
I'm just out of words to say it's just
it's just non-stop baffling yeah he he
dissect Ed the whole show all these
shows and
just I wonder if he got this idea from
like the snark people and they you know
what I mean like got him all riled up
like C man Jake little original baby
think so he might be one of the
moderators for all we know true I see
what you're saying though someone's giv
him some confidence yeah where everybody
externally was telling him don't do this
but like somewhere there I feel like
there was some group of people some
community that was saying that this is
good and important work
because and like who else would say that
I don't know but anyway the point is I'm
going to read it cuz I want to send love
to this person I've been watching H3 all
my life and found what an
want to send love to this cancer
uh this dude with cancer or person with
cancer look at the top comment you see
how it's being funny that's what we do
it's a comedy thing baby sorry
about your cancer me yeah
kissing my ass said uh the poster
this channel to actually me out of many
depressive episodes that being said and
I don't even know why I'm wasting my
little life come on I have left on
Reddit to post my feelings it didn't
take you that long to write
this a joke
right uh but anyways I'm just typing I
take it as a challenge by the way cuz
we've been getting like a fair amount of
like
really
difficult
messages and I take it as a challenge to
try to make somehow something really sad
and difficult into make a funny joke
from it it's very hard to
[Music]
do it's a project that I've been working
on yeah we get more and more of them
it's interesting yeah it has been
ramping up yeah I love you guys so much
my whole family just died in a car
accident and my grandma has cancer but
anyways could you say happy
birthday yeah can you wish my friend
happy 21st
birthday you
21 words as I'm thinking I'm Cancer
Sucks my grandma then my mom and now me
are going to probably die from it and
honestly it's funny he hearing jokes
about it see and it takes away from the
everyday nature of think about dying God
I love you HRI fam no homo no homo and I
hope the no homo and I hope the podcast
lives on for many years after I'm gone
well I don't know what your situation is
but uh we love you and um if there is a
chance to beat it I hope you uh do I do
actually reading that feel really I mean
I I do send the love to that person I
hope that they're doing
well person who posted on Reddit said
they'll most likely die and Ethan says I
hope you beat it which I find so funny
oh my God you don't know what funny is
that's kind of up Jake why would
you wish him well why would you not he
said I probably do you know what
probably
means he goes bro you should have been
done the right thing and told him to uh
that you're definitely going to die of
cancer good luck in the afterlife buddy
yeah you make it to Heaven
probably what a weird Point dude you so
weird what you're weird dude kept that
probably should have kept that to
yourself my guy
definitely because Ethan is the exact
type of person to get mad at someone for
telling him I'm sure you're fine oh I'm
sure you're fine but why you're not sure
of that I'm sure I know what do you mean
you're sure I don't like I didn't say
I'm sure they're fine yeah you a
completely different statement they said
I'm probably going to die of cancer and
I said I hope that you can beat it if if
there's a way to do it I hope you can do
it that is not the same thing yeah also
I'm being silly here once again people
say that I'm
sure death on that random person yeah
like the way I know that's not what he
meant but the way he phrased that was
way more up than what you
said dude this dude's going to die can
you just tell him like it is give it to
a die he said he still has some hope
left he said probably can you give him
the exact percentage 100% according to
him gives you the right to tell me that
in the next episode of his members only
podcast Ethan gives us a dramatic
telling of what's going on all right
here here's here's what's going on so
I'm going in on Tuesday for another for
a blood test followup and I'm being
referred to a rheumatologist which if
you don't know is a doctor that
specializes in autoimmune disease so
I've seen a hematologist now they're
referring me to see a rheumatologist
like like that that in itself is like
enough right I mean to close the case on
this like they're sending me to see
Specialists so it seems I don't yeah I
don't think it's answer but I think
there is a significant possibility that
I have an autoimmune disease and even
more possible it seems that it might be
lupus no Ethan that's not how that
works how who are you it's a great sound
bite though that is a good one yeah no
eat oh that's good we actually have to
sound bite the out of
this that's because all that I want I
want the sound bites of you to be the
only remnants of your presence
online and you need to go retire there's
a cheddar Mike m who says he's really
not nailing this job interview yeah this
is the worst this is going awful CV than
Boogie no I think this has Boogie buil
uh be true if he's trying to work for us
this is well I don't know but yeah you
might be like well Boogie is kind of
funny I work at a small gaming store
back in 2006 2007 I am disabled uh
recognized by the state of Arkansas but
also the United States government
there's that now the downside of that is
I am extremely depressed so there's some
mental health issues that we bring to
the table at least he's honest and then
physically I I am morbidly obese I have
no references uh no work history right
and no education right and when you
Google my name you might see rumors that
I beat my ex-wife and I also a
pedophile oh
Jesus I think Boogie's got him beat yeah
you can't beat Bo's the king of that
he's the goat really is as you were
referred to a doctor doesn't mean that
you're diagnosed with something in the
field that they specialize in also Ethan
said it's even more possible that he has
lupus but from what he shared that
information has not come from a medical
professional only chat GPT you don't
know that
I I think I might have lupus but
the weird thing is that I don't really
have significant
clinical
um uh symptoms you can tell how
disconnected this take is because as we
will later find out lupus can be a very
difficult and stressful diagnosis silly
dumb you just said it yourself
yeah so okay so maybe listen to that
exact sentence you just
said is it up to say that
I'm not going to say
it probably yeah probably probably n no
probably not self sensor that one yeah
just to get that's the uh the weird part
about all this and I guess it's making
it hard for them to diagnosed because we
caught this whole thing by accident I
mean I was just doing a a random checkup
you know just for health I hadn't done
it in a while and we switched to a new
um insurance company which I'm glad they
did cuz they're so much better if I was
with Kaiser I don't think I ever would
have gone through all this stuff cuzz
the bureaucracy is so insane I'm going
to try to ignore the insanely privileged
take that Ethan gave at the end there
saying that the Kaiser Permanente health
system wouldn't have helped him the same
go yourself dude shut the up
shut up I talk to doctors at Kaiser that
they won't order anas because they're
they're trained to actually save cost
there one my actually my dermatologist
who used to work for Kaiser told me that
she said she sometimes she tried to
order and similar types of blood work
and she'd get yelled at by the
administration for wasting money huh so
that is up I know exactly what
I'm talking about you little
what a douchebag and after
that sorry liia go ahead any sorry
you're just advocating for Better Health
Care like
you're essentially saying the exact
opposite of what he's implying that
you're saying yeah yeah yeah yeah mhm
and you after that after you were having
problems with that you told us if any of
us aren't happy we could switch as well
oh yeah BTS I love my new insurance and
I told everybody that they can switch to
it if they want but again Kaiser is not
bad it's just I think they're bad for
diagnosing like a chronic illness yeah I
know we've been with Kaiser for a few
years and we're we had two kids with
them mhm that were both very positive
experiences so I'm not Bastion Kaiser I
like I've never had an issue with them
at all but obviously it's like
everybody's experience is going to be
different so they're great for some
stuff and not great for other that's
it like we're going to have a baby with
our new carrier and I'm a little nervous
like I don't know me too because I'm so
used to the Kaiser Way the Kaiser one is
good we know our way around there we
know you know right so silly dumb
don't say you're nervous we're we're um
fishing for sympathy right now oh
button privileged ass ner nervous about
your wife giving
birth health plan that 13 million other
Americans are on and also his I he's
acting like I was like everyone with
Kaiser's a loser you
dork poor poor poor by the way Kaiser is
expensive I think I don't think it's
like a cheapo Insurance uh is it I was
heard I mean I was you pay for it so I
don't know it's more it's more expensive
than a lot of other yeah and you
got us like the best plan too so thanks
got that Platinum B yeah yeah all the
way all the way his employees every
single one of his employees are on
Kaiser through Ethan's benefit package I
mean what does this guy want people to
not have insurance and die thankfully we
no wait did you say that how did we get
through that good question you yeah
right I guess yeah I can answer it
no he's going to show you what he meant
all right let's see let's see you have
good health insurance thanks you you're
welcome yes and uh well hopefully you
guys do too otherwise then I guess
you're just going to have to die
broke and without doctors die die Jesus
moving on from the Bro
owned okay so let me just for my own uh
just for my own sake indulge me a minute
here uh here's all the times that I
donated to people for their medical
bills during this time at least that we
could find I got to go prep because
I Ethan can you pay my $6 radi uh
Radiology
Bill
yes 100 I'm not even kidding send it
that is one um here's another one
somebody said can we get all the trash
off the table doing it thank you
yeah and time I talk about this I'm
reminded about how fortunate I am to be
able to do all these things so if you
have medical bills that are
um crushing you or causing you problems
send it to Dan I'm going to pay I'm
going to pay one of them off Dan is
going to personally pay for them by the
way we ended up paying three I think
sorry Dan yeah we we ended up paying
crunching medical debt send it to Dan
he's got you send it to Dr D that was a
perfect Pause by the way on Dan's face
right there oh sorry
D I thought you were you were like okay
volunteering give it to Dan well we that
happened on the stream where someone's
like you know my my on the see you next
Tuesday uh right did they ever reach out
you know what no huh did they ever reach
out that's a shame I mean I actually had
several other people reach out because
of that anyway I remember yeah you know
what I I think I do remember that that
first person never did reach out right
we did pay it for it though I gave it to
three people yeah we I I got I got
plenty well you might not have to
imagine get in there Jennifer that
cancer in the ass oh yeah for real
actually cancer in the ass bro what is
he even talking about cancer doesn't
have have an anus are you saying to
the person with cancer in the ass are
you crazy I hope you get ass cancer and
die you son of a I'll cut your
throat I'll come to your house and kill
your children
that is not how I feel it's not that
serious Dr Phil we we paid off the
medical bills
right we did speaking of which because
last time I was talking to my doctor I
said I was going to pay off one person's
medical bills we chose three people that
emailed us M yada yada
yada $2,000 will change my life iconic
classic comment um so anyway
we tested the the weird elbows okay cuz
everyone was telling me have weird why
didn't you show that there's a symptom
for you of elbow so that one was
fine basically he says so the Ana test
is basically a diagnostic tool for lupus
and
lupus like
diseases so he says 15% of the
population will have a I don't know but
uh is it back did I miss it or richy boy
I think so Gumby looking ass Africa
World War is I appreciate the plug so
hyper flexive elbows uh sorry I don't
know
young where you going with
this whatever you guys remember it 2000
will change my
life uh and I don't know if we sent him
two maybe we did I don't remember it
happened a lot of times Lena not to Flex
that but like it's there's small
gestures and I'm happy to help people
it's just up that this dude acts
like I'm sure sure that I gave more
money away than donations we received
for lupus and you know that's not just
not a very good scam is it I want to
focus it's a weird scam more and him
saying that there are zero symptoms it
is very very rare to have a lupus
diagnosis with no symptoms at all not
saying it's impossible but with all the
other things I've mentioned going
against him Ethan's lupus Glory seems to
be lupus Glory Glory Glory how
halus Glory Glory
[Music]
halus getting farther and farther away
my only I guess symptom is that you guys
remember how I kept getting rashes we
thought it was from the F fish so I I'm
getting really mild rashes on my face
you guys remember the one I had a while
ago and then I've been getting just
slight rashes here and here they'll go
away they're really slight but that's a
symptom of autoimmune disease other than
that by the way after this it came back
stronger that's one was basically stayed
on my face it's been getting better
slowly over time but I know it's been
months and it's just it's literally
still there I don't know what it is also
the lead into this clip was emphasizing
zero symptoms and then plays a clip of
you talking about the symptom that you
have what like what is happening here
and just as a general note too like
there's always like the meme of like
don't Google something because you'll
think you're dying well imagine you say
you're sick like Ethan does on whatever
you know he comes in sick you have
millions or thousands of people telling
you you have different things yeah it's
going to start to with you like
every time one of us mentioned something
like when I said that I think I'm
allergic to gluten or whatever I got so
many different U messages which I
appreciate but yeah it's just this whole
thing is so ironic to me it's
it's crazy it's really it's so
unself-aware it's so bad faith I just I
continually Wonder like why did he do
this he must brainwashed yeah somebody
somewhere convinced this man to ruin it
all yeah with the worst takedown video
in YouTube
history
wait what's up ducky I think just
keeping an eye on him he's wandering a
little bit there he goes
now okay you probably needs to go potty
oh
maybe he's laying okay you have symptoms
I don't really have significant
clinical
um uh symptoms we can either take this
one of two ways Ethan conveniently
forgot to mention his symptoms over the
last month or so or dude you're such an
he scrambling to mention things
that could be perceived as symptoms
rashes on his face could be a sign of
lupus or they could be eczema jeez I
keep bringing up eczema it's almost like
that's what it could be any bone issues
no okay doct do the MD the
eczema expert the autoimmune expert this
guy is crossing Fe this is Doctor
house this man really needs to get he's
wasting his talents on YouTube get him
to John Hopkins Hopkins
immediately no that's the thing I don't
have joint pain I don't have bone pain I
don't have fuzzy look at me saying he
goes he's being so deceptive about his
lupus to me being like I don't have any
symptoms Vision I don't have loss of
vision I don't have any of that I
have a feeling I have Lupus I don't know
why have you considered you're faking
it I wish man I don't know how to fake a
blood test but I wish I could oh yeah so
that's another thing like tingling in
the extremities I don't have anything
like that I don't have any
really symptoms like I said the only
reason we've caught this is just pure
chance and the blood test and you know
my mom has an autoimmune disease she has
like ulcer ulcer colitis ulcer itis
colitis I don't know I know that this is
straying away from the topic at hand but
what does your mom have don't you think
this guy has a fetish for being the
biggest in the world you're really
GNA say that I didn't say it right well
growing up she just called it colitis so
that's but I know there's like a a
medical term for it which is like ulcer
ulcerative colitis or something like
that but go ahead Dr D and tell me um
real quick cam is sending even though
he's not here today for real we got
stuff sending a couple things
yeah this is awesome with the message
you ain't getting in the club pal
emergency room main entrance Dr dittle
is bouncing he's gay keeping the
entrance to the hospital oh my God
that's so funny Dr dittle come on I'm
sick let me in wait I didn't see this
one earlier yeah there's another one the
lopus glory no glory glory crowning you
lupus Glory from chbt this so good
that's so
true so
true that's good good I love this loopus
glaze I'm glazed up with that lupus
baby oh here's another one earlier from
cam we missed a lot CH TPT says it's
lupus Dr do little I say it's eczema
that's a great that's a great good
doctor you could flip it too it should
be it should be Jake yelling at you and
then you and uh Dr Han at the bottom
just saying I have
Lupus right I have
Lupus I have Lupus Dr
Han Dr Han I have Lupus Dr
Han all right Google come on get your
together think if autoimmune
disease runs in your family and your mom
has ulcerative colitis you would at
least know how to pronounce it my guess
so what is your point that I'm lying
also that's so mean also again have you
watched the show Ethan says everything
wrong like one of his that is not
indicative of anything him not saying it
right so what oh my God what is he is he
saying that I'm lying about my mom had
colitis maybe he's kind of like throwing
it out there he's saying if she really
did have Colitis you know how to say it
yeah yeah I guess he is he's saying I'm
lying about my mom having autoimmune
diseas my mom who's a big part of the
show and talks all the time publicly I'm
lying about something that she would e
and my my mom is so naive if I was doing
that she would for sure just be like I
don't have Colitis online someone talk
to her something right but no she does
I'm sure she wishes she didn't it's it's
very it's been uh challenging for her
Jake you scumbag loser what would you
know about it she had a whole Health
scar that was actually documented on our
Channel such a little scumbag a few
years ago how dare you how dare you even
talk about my mom like this these nuts
you what is he sick
with o I actually don't know but maybe
we can diagnose he has lime he has sugma
I
believe how long you had Suma how long
wait does he have an official Lyme
disease or is that just him saying I got
line you know what I mean U he doesn't I
don't I don't recall if he specifies but
he's a doctor so oh well I need to know
did you get the the official uh
diagnosis I'd like to talk
to your doctor
please how much you want how much you
want to bet his doctor was like it's
probably not lime don't worry about it
no I don't from what I understand he was
genuinely sick uh as a young man yeah
he's I believe that he was he talked
about it yeah unfortunately it's it did
Dam damage his brain and uh although he
see appears to be fine it's he's just
another victim of chronic illness and
it's just so sad and tragic you know you
get that crotch rot it is
tragic got the bra in your family and
your mom has ulcerative colitis you
would at least know how to pronounce it
my guess is lime shut up Sam why you say
that lime I don't think lime disease can
cause elevated antier let me ask chat
DBT I've been I've been doing a lot of
chatting with uh CH by the way I know
everyone's silly but like chat GPT is
really good for general questions like
it knows everything at this point it's
probably better than Google I mean
there's inaccuracies but Google is dog
at this point you will almost
always get the wrong answer from Google
so if I and if I go like hey uh do
people with Lyme disease get Ana
elevated Ana and it says no which it did
then you can say can you link me your
source and you click it and then you see
it's like so easy information but Dr D
doesn't know how to use it well he went
to medical school he gets his he pulls
his information from the
sourcewell of all human knowledge by the
way I played Divinity 2 over the break
oh yeah how' you like that I beat the
whole thing on tactician wow that's
impressive it took me a long time to
beat it he's a tactical Master it was
fun though it was good it was fun that's
cool yeah I started a new game in uh
Balor and as
tactical tactician as tactician you're
ready yeah you're ready are you doing
that are you gonna do that I'm gonna do
another playthrough at some point yeah I
I'm I'll get i'll get back around to it
eventually it come on got GPT about this
you know what I mean can lime disease
cause Ella elevated antier lime disease
caused by bacteria it's not typically
associated with a risen antier yeah I
don't think it's Lyme disease there's
not even really Lyme disease here in La
I think there's like five people like a
year get Lyme disease in LA or less yeah
exactly there's zero lime disease in
California it's like super super rare
okay this one struck close to home dumb
I know I'm right on that I've
literally look I've looked it up
recently like there's almost no Lyme
disease on the west coast it's almost
predominantly uh located to the east
coast like Northeast Coast but go ahead
and tell me chat gbt that how many lime
disease cases did California get in
or Los Angeles even first video that
you've seen of mine I've been sick ever
since I was three years old yeah I'm so
sorry that I didn't watch your videos
bro you know here I I'm finally quality
like this we've been miss I'm watching
your video I'm acknowledging please
dud here you just stop just put the
camera
away these moments might be the origin
story of Ethan's greatest
foe I don't think so I don't think this
guy has it in him
California 106 confirmed cases in 2020
in California yeah that is exceedingly
rare yeah it's super rare lime disease
rates are generally lower in California
because while the Western fence lizard
may act as a host for the tick immature
stages its blood contains a protein that
kills uh I'm not going to Mis pronounce
this and Jake on my so uh whatever the
carrier of the disease is shout out
what's the name of that bug or lizard uh
what was it called um Western Fence
liard dude shout out that's badass that
they B Berg doery B bergery ex bergery
that's that's how you say it is that
right yeah nailed it mhm uh yeah so
there's something in their blood protein
that uh that kills it in the tick so hey
silly I actually know more than
you about your own illness suck it
sh but
that no I mean that's probably not true
what you just said let's hear what we
can acknowledge that that you're joking
you're joking years I was misdiagnosed
over and over in and out of wheelchairs
until I got diagnosed with chronic lime
disease Ethan Klein just had a you were
in a wheelchair have you considered that
you're just
lazy okay
maybe has he considered that I don't
think so I haven't seen you asked you
asked the other day if this still worked
I'm going to try it right now yeah there
you go oh yeah bring we got to bring the
button and the sound too I don't know
why the sound didn't play but I guess
the buttons that's what he does to me
though he's I'm just I get what you're
trying to say but let me see the
doctor's notee dude says you can't walk
he would be like Justin Bieber has lyme
disease he's doing okay yeah exactly
superar guess maybe we need to let him
finish but I'm again not sure what point
he's making here you you said that it's
probably not Lyme disease cuz it's
really rare in California and he said
I have Lyme disease it's like yes
let's hear you know he says oh now I
know about lime okay go ahead lot of
information about a disease that he's
completely uneducated on his chat GPT
said that Lyme disease isn't likely to
cause an elevated Ana but I asked chat
GPT myself and it said the complete you
dumbass opposite almost as if diagnosing
I I see what he did he says is it
possible that it
can cuz you can see Lyme disease can
cause a positive Ana where I asked it is
it likely is it possible is it likely or
something like
that s and it said the complete opposite
almost as if diagnosing via AI chat Bots
isn't always it's not a real diagnosis
you dumb it's not nobody thought
it was God I hate this dude he really is
the
worst liable way to get medical
information I am walking proof of
someone who had a positive Ana from lime
disease chronic lime is actually very
likely to Branch off into other
autoimmune disease es like in my
experience I was diagnosed with
psoriatic arthritis and immune
deficiency disorder and a bunch of other
stuff that to be honest I don't remember
cuz I was 12 years old you don't
remember convenient then did it really
Happ
happen bro I don't believe
you no I'm not doubting him he he was
sick from what I from what I understand
he was he was ill and he what did have a
chronic illness I'm not questioning that
just being
silly really a will
wheelchair you couldn't walk
come on man
up and I was trying not to kill myself
according to Los Angeles Public Health
you laughed after that joke you laughed
you made a joke about yourself and you
laughed cuz I was 12 years old and I was
trying not to kill myself
according how dare you minimize
the issue of unal
living how dare
you I got you big time to Los Angeles
Public Health the number of confirmed
Lyme disease cases in Los Angeles County
has varied from 0 to eight cases a year
but that's so little in the same article
they say the diagnosis of Lyme disease
may be difficult 0 to eight cases a year
in La most years in LA from what I saw
remember looked at the data is
zero that's all I said man and I was
right because of many other diseases
that cause symptoms such as fever
headache fatigue and body ache
laboratory tests are of so you're saying
there's even
less other diseases can mimic
lime awesome not sensitive the
difficulty of diagnosing is irrelevant
you were just purely talking about
somebody said you might have L right and
it's and it's also difficult to diagnose
in other states too and yet the numbers
are much higher there like it's still
difficult yeah I'm seeing 6,700 new
cases of Lyme disease in New York that's
a big difference yeah yeah and there's
and that's in the entire state of New
York Which is less population than
California still pretty rare though by
population yeah sure I mean it is a
relatively rare disease but yeah you're
right it's way rare the fact that it's
so rare are you sure you have that bro
cuz like it's so rare and it's really
hard to diagnose it's rare and hard to
diagnose are you sure about that pal
buddy buddy no I believe him just being
silly we make that
clear spefic or consistent and are
frequently misinterpreted okay so I did
tell chbt my symptoms and Chachi BT also
thinks the most likely uh diagnosis is
lupus but there's a chance that I don't
have anything and and it's just a fluke
but that that that's I'll be honest
I want to be optimistic about it but
that doesn't make sense to me cuz
there's just too many different signals
going off in my blood work you know what
I mean this clip brings me so much joy
because you will find out at the end of
this video that this is a complete lie
chat GPT never God you
dumbass close the laptop bro Pawn It
Pawn all of your equipment all this big
what is this what is this like a a
switching an audio board pawn it wor
start a new hobby please eBay get into
rocks or some like
Colleen rocks are sweet and you can say
anything to them and they don't respond
because they're in adamant
all thought that the most likely
diagnosis was lupus ever and Ethan outs
himself in the worst way possible but we
have to keep on addressing these claims
until we can get to that part trust me
it's really bad the only thing that
would be worse would be like Ethan
ranking diseases on how much he wants
them or something like that that's a
pretty funny idea pick oh that's a funny
idea that'd be funny if he did that I
did to pick a disease out of a hat
between Ms and lupus Dan can you do a
poll what would you guys rather have MS
or Lup cuz I feel like maybe I might
rather have Lupus you know what I mean
let's do a poll which autoimmune disease
is your favorite we got the poll going
down let's see are you guys team lupus
or team Ms Let's go Team let's go teams
I I've never said this in my life and
you know I hate when people say that but
comedians just can't tell jokes anymore
you just can't you can't joke about
anything can't joke about anything
anymore man those comedians I mean this
dork getting mad about it is uh not the
best evidence of yeah we say you know in
the comedy world we say we're the last
line of defense but
last because this is where where the
woke meets the
wall he's such a
Workman where the woke meets the wall
baby that's some words where right
there me Joe damn I got to get on
that elk meat to elevate my
brain taking the lead let's go
that's right team lupus 80% let's
go
dude lupus for
Selena lupus for my girl Selena let's go
right
now we team lupus out here boy yeah
that's what I'm thinking too being
pretty silly team lupus out here on God
did your doctor actually say it lus or
is it just chat
chbt the doctor sending me to a
rheumatologist
so like I said earlier my dear Ean a
referral doesn't mean a diagnosis and
hey when did I say I had lupus
so condescend you
silly little my dear
Ethan why did you do this
man uh
that's just why did you do this man Jake
we could have been
family maybe in another Universe you
send me your application I take a look
and I like what I see you come to meet
us you work with us years
decades do do but why did you have to
take this rout and now I have to banish
you from YouTube dude now you must pause
on all of your
electronics you don't you are not
allowed back on
[Music]
YouTube
gabish let me say
this let's take a walk to the pawn
shop anyway
sorry you finish that perfectly the song
just ended that was perfect timing I I
got to give it to you there oh thank you
thank you an answer to the question that
was asked did your doctor actually say
it might be lupus or is it just chat gbt
then he proceeds to say the kind of
doctor he's going to who says that I
don't hook up the fans here I am all my
medical records my deepest darkest fears
it's all for you guys right here right
now Buckingham Palace is pleased to
announce that I Ethan Klein probably
have Lupus big news Ethan has that's
funny that's funny dude how is anyone no
I I don't have an official diagnosis
I'll be honest but I think I'd probably
do if there's anything wrong with me I
have Lupus I'm team lupus so went to the
hematologist hoping it would be like
you're fine no more problems and a
tighter through the roof one to
320 is not that high what do you stop
that is high everybody says it's high
strong positive who is everybody in this
situation Chachi okay argue against me
is 320 not a strong positive T your
doctors because 1 to 300 my doctor said
that to me that it's a strong positive
and 20 is elevated but not as Ethan says
through the roof after this
Ethan says again that he diagnosed
himself via chat 1 to 320
dude right now I had a long conversation
with uh um chat GPT about my health why
you so why you so defensive about like
chronic illness just be sick and
off just be sick and happy man like what
the why do you you know what I mean
we don't and I say this as someone that
might have uh I have Lupus I'm staying
it here today no as someone with lupus
let me say this we don't want you as
our just go be chronically and go be
happy you do not we do not claim you
okay keep on keep riding whatever was
this charity keep it on keep keep keep
it going keep it keep it yeah off I
speak for the whole lupus Community when
I say off I don't give a about
your feelings you are offensive to me
yes can you imagine you did end up
getting diagnosed he would be so
my god well I mean it yeah I think I I
think that I probably if I had to guess
and again oh boy just just for J I don't
know right it's all based
on this is all hypothetical oh yeah okay
but because of like the rash that has
stayed because of the fatigue and I've
had like weird I've been having weird
digestion problems and I had an elevated
thing in my stool if I go back and get
the stool and it's elevated and then I
need to go for a philosophy I probably
have a an irritable bowel disease
probably that makes sense which is also
an autoimmune disorder okay I got you
yeah of course it is yeah it's
autoimmune so when I get a posit but
Jake here's what I want you to
do e with or without the
diagnosis you erase the video that's
good good start you
make you know what I was going to say
make me a no I don't even want that he's
like it's working just go just go be by
yourself and your just go be sick
somewhere else man delete your off
we don't want you here go be sick
somewhere
else and it makes me
s says of of all the possible uh
Solutions most likely would be lupus the
other reason that we suspect lupus wait
bro you could have condensed this video
a lot dummy like this whole middle
section is just you being like lupus
chat PT lupus he listened he said this
shut up at least learn how to make
a good video that's why nobody's
watching your dude cuz your
sucks you're boring was it
monetized you bet your goddamn ass it
was I don't know I think it was I I
don't know I don't know I don't know
either but it is seems unnecessarily
long well if anybody's profiting off
loopus it sure ain't me buddy well it
was dropped when ad Revenue was the
highest true true December and also
again as um Subs go up people mention
that he does have a
merch thing that has the same name as
his charity keep going or whatever and
he doesn't disclose it up right I don't
think I don't know if he discloses it
anywhere he says it's for awareness but
of the merch he he donates only
10% what and it has the name of the of
the
of the nonprofit charity on it that's
very think I think a lot of people that
go to that probably assume that their
purchase is going
towards um towards the charity right so
my boys getting some guacamole out of
this lupus
Scandal you know what I mean interesting
I would call that allegedly allegedly
allegedly we like to allege things here
don't we oh yes he went from saying that
chat GPT thinks it's lupus to now we
think it's lupus we in this situation
being an AI chat bot in Ethan Klein the
other reason that we suspect lupus is
just because I keep I keep getting these
weird face rashes now with lupus you get
like these big butterfly rashes it's
very confusing I don't get any rashes
here but I do get I got a new rash now
here right here on both sides of my nose
it took me a year to determine I had
Celiac not lupus interesting but
Celiac's easy you just stop eating wheat
right well for someone in a $9 million
house yes but for other people you dumb
what silly stupid what coward
ly I'm running out of goddamn words to
use dude how's that related like what oh
oh what my mom is a celc dumb
stupid Punk loser idiot loser that
related to what house you live in
because because I'm like well people who
have Celiac like me for example it
becomes a huge deal because according to
a study out of D huzi medical school on
average gluten-free products were 2 42%
more expensive than regular products I
think most okay okay what's that got to
do with me because I said got a new
ration now here right here on both sides
of my nose it took me a year to
determine I had Celiac not lupus
interesting but Celiac easy you just
stop eating wheat right well you dumb
obviously I meant it's easy in
terms of like if you avoid eating gluten
then you're not sick right yeah unlike
other lupus diseases that could be a lot
more yeah problematic but he's he's like
nah he just hates poor people yeah
you're think well you would have what
they call uh rich people uh itis itis
yeah if if you don't then it's expensive
it's autoimmune it's an autoimmune
illness man that line though the $9
million house that's like one of the top
10 lines that all the hate videos use
they love to bring up the stop worrying
about my money
man worry about your guacamole from
loopy you're getting a little loopy on
Lupus buddy he's getting high in his
own
[Music]
overruled thank
you yeah let's button that out nothing I
buttoned it so we're good that's why you
don't go to the bathroom during the show
Dan well we're good we're good we're
good yeah we're
good schol on average gluten-free
products were 242 more expensive than
regular products I think most people
lopus can live a fairly normal life
expectancy which is good I'll suffer the
whole way I don't care I just want to be
there for the boys I'm sure you're fine
but why you're not sure of that I'm sure
I know you already showed this man you
mean you're sure I don't like when
people say that sure you're why are you
sure what gives you the right to tell me
that you go man this something really
bad I'm afraid of happening I'm sure
you're fine it's like you're not sure
how do you know Ethan's like yeah as
someone suffering from lupus I hate when
people undermine my issues also didn't
say have Lupus literally you said that
not me lupus isn't that bad and I'm just
glad it isn't cancer you know of all the
yeah yeah yeah I'd be happy too i'
rather live and be sick than die
yeah I mean I know some people do die of
Lupus that does happen but cancer is I
don't know if you know this it is
actually a fatal disease yes
yes things it could have been I'll take
lupus I guess you I mean take us a
little loopy but it's not certain it is
lupus right no no no I give it maybe a
50% chance lupus is that your chance or
is that what the doctor saying it's a
that was well no the doctor would never
give you a percentage like that I would
say that was um potentially after some
coaxing of chat GPT I forced it to get
I'm being silly about the whole you got
you got to stop with that so it's
possible How likely is the possibility
that it's nothing there's a chance but
it's it doesn't make sense that it's
nothing there is a chance that it's
nothing but like with the white blood
cells the platelets the antier dude just
please stop talking to chat GPT why chat
GPT is Pro that's Lou not me
that's Lou Lou that's good advice Lou is
the go he's giving good advice listen to
Lou yeah nice to him to include Lou it's
good to see him nice to see you Lou good
to see you Lou hopefully we'll see you
this year good New Year yeah in this
time like you need positivity and no it
it doesn't bring me down I need to know
I need to know even with an employee
telling him to stop looking at chaty
after admitting to his name's Zach
yeah he didn't even message me you
Jake hold on this guy is a fake fan his
name is Lou
actually l l call me L for lus I go by
L I have l
boy I'm going start calling him Lou Dr
Lou
Little Dr lupus coaxing it into saying
what he wants to hear Ethan gives I need
to know as an excuse I think he already
knew the answer a long time ago but
sympathy from people around him felt
better than just saying it was from a
pre-existing esophageal problem now my
moment so again he he's di he's saying
it's gird it's just gird bro is saying
she's mad at you for not telling her
about this yeah I know Mom I I didn't
tell you about it I guess I should have
expected you hear the show it's because
you would be so annoying about it you
know you would be very mature take here
Mom why are you criticizing my relation
with my mom what the does that have
to do with you makes everything 10 times
weird
can you leave my mom out of it your did
you forget that you just accused like
her or me of lying about having like
like don't talk to my mom don't talk
about my
mom your
mom your mom is so
fat she got her own ZIP code I found my
uh I found my tip just fine when I was
giving it to your
mom that's big tip yo your mom's so fat
when she sits around the house she sits
sits around the house
bro that's my favorite
mhm um you would be so cringe and
annoying if I told you my medical
worries yeah dude yes that's
like the fact that he included that is
nuts it's like I mean this whole thing
is nuts but wow it's the constant like
um I can diagnose myself I don't like
when other people do it this to me is
the grand slam of all Grand Slams I can
diagnose myself I don't like when other
people do it I'm not even going to
speculate what he means by this because
I want you as the viewer to think about
it on your own but nice I'm not going to
possibly try to deduce any meaning from
this but I'm sure it's there if you
think about it hard enough a bad English
teacher what an idiot let's just take
everything into context Ethan Klein had
no symptoms got a routine checkup had
some elated levels doctor said it was
fine and most likely related to a prior
medical issue then he did not say that
you're you're literally lying he totally
Miss understanding your statements on
purpose I I never said okay saying that
he did hundreds of hours of research I
know which is he's he's admitting to
defam he's admitting to defamation
because I want you as the viewer to
think about it on your own but let's
just take everything into context Ethan
kin had no symptoms wrong got a routine
checkup yes had some elevated levels yes
doctor said it was fine and no no well
kind of they said they said it's
probably fine but if you want to see a
hematologist I can refer you most likely
related to a prior medical issue he did
not say that nor did I weird then Ethan
admittedly CES chat GPT into telling him
he likely has
lupus okay my blood work came back same
as yours 30% people have abnormal Ani
tiders and do not have Lupus rely on
your symptoms more why do you care about
what jet why you so obsessed with jbt
the blood work is the that's the the
pudding you know what I mean I showed
all that so my symptoms is is part
of the confusing part I don't really
have any of the god you're so boring
this this is interesting did this from
you Cam no Ethan we were getting
somewhere and you cut yourself off with
something weren't you doing a list what
happened related an employee sent you
someone donated their hard-earned money
to give you a very valid suggestion and
because it was more logical than
anything Ethan said in this episode he
brushed it off why didn't you say
something to us oh bro you got to stop
talking about my mom you better get my
mom's name out your
mouth that's some dude dude how
dare
you my mom's got more keep on and are
Pinky than you have in your
whole body she's keeped on longer than
you could ever dream of keeping on that
L it's just there's I don't know for
sure you know what I mean it's just
something I've been thinking about I
don't know I don't know what it is wait
that directly contradicts Ethan saying
at the beginning of the segment
Buckingham Palace is pleased to announce
that I Ethan Klein probably have lupus
that's a oh my God you're such an idiot
brain numbing almost like talking to his
mother who has a history of chronic
illness makes Ethan shut down or at
least realize his claims are wild his
mother goes on to try and talk to him in
a more understandable less chat GPT
diagnos way well you do you know you do
get tired there it is you
see well you know it could be a number
of things maybe you're just anemic Ethan
didn't tell his
mom I'm not anemic by the way I just did
a full blood panel so just so you know
Jake doitt I'm not a
nemic or his wife I'm glad I talk about
I've been stressing hard since this
morning yeah I didn't even know about
his thoughts until they were brought up
on the show which backs my argument that
this was all content brained if it
wasn't for cont dude it's so ironic he
says that like this is the most content
brained misstep of all time like you
content your brained yourself off
YouTube I'm serious
man there's nothing our audience loves
more than listening to you talk about
lupus
it's I mean he's not wrong it was fire
content it was fire content but that but
I but that's part of what we do is I
make the in my life the more
personal you know the more emotional the
the more compell it that's what I bring
I'm an open
book I have opened my life up all the
way for people there's nothing that I
don't talk about
and that's part of you know I think
the the charm of of of the show I I
think I don't know but but that's just
part of my what I
do you loser idiot
scumbag pasty can I say pasty or is
that pretty pasty he is very pale yeah
my look like Casper yeah you can say it
Casper
ass Casper ass looking pale
can I call him
melin the melin
man that's usually fat yeah they'll spin
like you're calling him fat no he's not
fat but he does look like sty like he's
made of rubber not Lena he's made of
rubber tires yeah he's doughy he looks
soft and and I'm a soft person so yeah
yeah I'm not calling him from softy from
one softy it seems like he actually lost
a lot of weight which is great I'm happy
for him for that or based on the old
videos I saw even you with him I think
he he looked heavier so well done on
that and terrible on everything else in
your
life I think he looks great pasty but
good I agree we shouldn't even talk
about his looks that's up that's
true he looks great we shouldn't even
address it really gone all the way
around it's it's a shame to even address
his
looks you're going to look so hot four
eyes look at ass
nerd For
Eyes crazy it's like these glasses you
wear glasses these
glasses doesn't that couch look so
uncomfortable what is it the couch looks
like it it's so hot in the summer
dude your back is probably so sweaty
Jake s that does look like sweaty sweaty
couch there we can like just be mean
about his background instead yeah that's
good
off the internet I'm talking on YouTube
about my experiences 15 surgeries and
two years after being directly affected
going through health problems are a very
difficult time in turn you're awesome
your health problems are way more way
more important than mine yeah dude
you're so right I should just sit back
and listen to the people with real
medical issues like Jake do little do
better such a weird gatekeep into
content while undermining other people's
experiences is a huge problem a few
episodes later Ethan gives another
health update where he says that he had
a CBC panel and everything came back
lowered and within the normal to high
range then Ethan finally goes to the
Rheumatology appointment where the
doctor gives him this information
yesterday I saw a rheumatologist this
facial rash I'm getting here I'm getting
it at the corner of my eyes and I'm
getting it here on my nose so that was
one of the concerns lupus causes facial
rash but he told me and which is kind of
what I read is that Lupus rash is pretty
much all on the cheeks yeah it's all
right here in this kind of area I have
not had any rashes there so he looks
closely at the rashes and stuff and he
says he believes it to be most likely
eczema outside of his prior medical
condition this is the only time we've
gotten a
diagnosis great that'd be good yeah
that'd be awesome after yeah so what
he's so what I just did a test and
it's elevated you know what I mean you
in a box do you know what that's
like don't talk to me about
in the Box going well I I'd
like to know if you haven't in a
box don't talk to me cuz taking
all the in the Box
Glory in a
box yeah he said he said it might be
eczema but um it it doesn't respond to
usual eczema treatments like I talked
about which he omits is that I went to
the dermatologist to treat it and when I
got the steroids creamed it made
everything worse mhm um and it's still
on my face
now uh
but also there's the The Chronic fatigue
and my elevated blood levels and
stuff all this I'm not done okay all
right you're just some eczema I'm not
all all right all right no I'm
eczema doesn't cause a positive Ana Dan
oops Ethan I know that we are responding
in the another good sound yeah Heat of
the Moment but that's very
false I have a feeling he's wrong about
this can actually cause a positive Ana
according to a study out of nepon
medical school 20 to 30% of patients
withon studies every day pull almost a
study for anything when it comes to
medical research like if you're making
such a bad faith article uh argument
yeah you could look up almost anything
there studies of everything I
mean yeah let's ask chat
gbt you know I'm starting to question
everything I don't even know if you've
actually ever done crack now I question
I swear to God I smoked crack once I SM
an elevated an
Ana let's
see chat GPT and this is four so before
you come at me know that this is the
real right
here eczema uh is a atopic dermatitis
Prim primarily a skin condition
characterized by dry itchy skin and it's
associated with allergic reactions an
Ana test on the other hand is used to
detect autoimmune
disorders in general eczema is not
directly associated with Ana elevated
Ana levels are more more commonly linked
to autoimmune disorders like lupus uh
rheumatoid arthritis and skod Derma
sorry I miss said
it go make a whole video about it
however in some cases individuals with
chronic inflammatory conditions or
certain other autoimmune disorders might
also exhibit skin symptoms similar to
eczema it's important to remember that
the presence of elevated nna does not
diagnose blah blah blah so I mean he's
just he's just like can it
happen yeah
like you're lying though you're wrong
about that so sure about it being ex the
thing too is you read is like lupus is
often times misdiagnosed as eczema or
eczema is sometimes misdiagnosed as
lupus it just it goes against this whole
video the way that he like certain you
have eczema why are you diagnosing Ean
anyway bro i' be you okay can you D can
you send me some meds that work on it
because that would be awesome since
you're i' like a prescription you know
send it to my
Pharmacy for anti-nuclear antibodies
finally we are at the part that forced
me to make this video as a viewer I gave
Ethan the benefit of the doubt until
this happened the rheumatologist after
checking more of my blood points doesn't
believe that I have Lupus there's other
bio markers for it and they were all
negative really but my facal rashes are
just getting worse they're not going
away he told me next step to see
dermatologist and see if they can tell
us what they think about these rashes so
I stopped treating it with this uh
steroid fascinating and it's just
coming back so so much I'm going to try
to get it as bad as it can just
naturally be so the DM can get a good
look are you mad that I don't have Lupus
Dan I'm not mad but no you seem mad you
seem annoyed that I don't have Lupus
this man's been farming lupus for a
month there is something wrong best
guess I set him off you probably gave
him the idea video no I'm sorry I put
the idea in his head Jake you ruined
Jake's life Jake there's thing called
shtick we're doing shtick here we just
can't tell jokes anymore more people
oops oops was lupus sorry I don't have
Lupus Dan was it the best guess or was
it your guess no was the best
gued it was the most likely again I
guess this drives to the point that Ela
was making of starting to doubt that
this guy was really a fan cuz if he's
about to use this as a like does he not
like we have like an adversarial thing
we do we I you know I Harang you on the
show all the time about everything I
think you might be right I think he had
me really fool big fan dude maybe he's
just like kind of a fan maybe he knows
about the
show ducky what you getting into all
right you can do that it's chewing on
the green
screen I'm glad you don't have Lupus
obvious do sound like
it okay to be fair I'm going to confess
something to you guys I told CH chat BT
chat GBC all my symptoms yeah and I said
make a list based on How likely you
think it is lupus was number one but
there was one I didn't tell you guys
that was above lupus uhoh it was that
it's I'm probably
fine it's all it's really just a funny
joke there to bring that out now it's
funny that's why people
laugh I said do you think what's more
likely lupus or that it's just a false
reading and they said most likely it's a
false reading based on the stats of no
symptom you are
diabolical but it was close it was close
they had to Crunch the
I'm being silly I did a f I did it I
brought it out to be funny I you know
yeah we say you know in the comedy world
we say we're the last line of
defense so
true it's how I feel every day coming
here you would literally sign off you'd
be like all right guys I've got Loop no
I gen believe I had Lo D the anti TI are
still raised people don't and and I'm
inflamed man it's not
nothing well before we dig into
that a little bit more let's break down
the sentence he just said I told chat
GPT all of my symptoms and I said make a
list
based and then laughter this whole time
chpt never told you it was lupus
you're the only person oh it said
oh what happened is Ducky want
oh doggies ducky you Lena you can put
Alfred you don't have to protect
Alfredo is he trying to play with him
yeah he's just trying to play this puppy
is bullying Alfredo right now you can
put Alfredo down L is he he lives with
this every day he can handle it no
usually they start playing and have
fun it's fun 7 time 75% of the times
they'll start playing the other 25%
Alfredo will try to kill
him so we'll see what it is he's yeah
he's got so much energy it's crazy it
was lupus you can't even blame AI on
this AI said that you were most likely
fine and you admit it and you took
donations from people who actually have
this diagnosis and everything
was okay later why is what the donations
thing man he's incapable of like sensing
any humor at all it's
crazy there might be a thing there you
might be right is there a thing where
you can't do humor I don't know I'm not
a
doctor I'm not a doctor I just love is
just like being dumb yeah being an idiot
dumbass that's why I think condition
where you have zero understanding of of
humor by the way the the list wasn't
like you 100% are fine it was like you
you're probably fine most likely if not
is you have
Lupus is that not enough for you for
someone to worry about that's not enough
to worry about there's a there's a
condition called sarcasm blindness oh
really
interesting the hell never heard of that
before never heard Jak listen up
buddy also known as sarcasm also known
as doitt synd
agnosia Jake do better condition is a
well read it for all of us let's see uh
is a condition called sarcasm blindness
also known as sarcasm
agnosia it is a condition which the
individual is unable to understand
sarcasm and interpret it correctly
condition is associated with certain
neurological disorders and brain
injuries it may also be associated with
some psychc psychiatric conditions such
as schizophrenia I don't think he has
that but but who
knows I yeah I think that's a fair
assumption although again I'm not a
doctor and I never claimed to be I'm not
a
doctor on we find out that brain damage
is likely though it is possible and very
likely he lied about having lupus to
someone with lupus' face in one of the
interviews on the red carpet he never
said I have Lupus I never said I have L
never once never
once lame disease he's got lame disease
so you don't have lime disease he's got
lame
dise that makes so much sense yo Jake I
need to see your official diagnosis on
the lime not because I doubt you but
just because if you're going to start
questioning other people then you need
to Pony up Mr uh keep going. l so let's
see the paperwork you know what I mean I
want that I need it otherwise you're
lying I see people in the chat saying uh
uh autism too uh I didn't want to say
that but um I didn't want to say that
Dan
okay well you didn't so that's fine I I
even if I was thinking it I would never
have said that okay that's good um I I
was going to make the point that I know
that we have uh a substantial um
proportion of our audience that is on
the Spectrum though and they seem to be
able to understand humor stand no I'm
just based off of there's people in the
chat saying I have autism D be chill
come
on part of the YouTube Analytics
I'm kidding it's just funny is a funny
yeah a large portion of our audience is
autistic I mean I I I don't have a
specific stat on that but just based off
of uh what people are saying in the chat
right now people self-identifying as I
have autism there's a lot of um autistic
people everywhere they're they're
wonderful uh it is a my brother has
autism it is a wide spectrum so my point
was just that Kidd being autistic does
not preclude understanding humor
sometimes it does but not always yeah
and I didn't say that I didn't say that
I didn't think it that or or all these
people watching have no idea that this
is a comedy show they think that this is
just
serious they been watching for years and
they had no idea this is a comedy show
they're actually about to go to medical
school and they're just
watching prep we love the autistic
they're great we kid them and we love
them we don't kid them we just love them
we love you you're very special
exactly
the loopus bonding with one of the girls
there
you you can't do that said she said
what's the problem you're doing with
right
now my dog dying I was going to say that
Baker what's your problem are you
kidding all right uh I have Lupus I
think I have Lupus I blame everything on
Lupus lupus Queen yeah that's what's
happening yeah now some people outside I
I talk to that
girl I I don't know if she was watching
the show she was she so she was
following so she's like I have Lupus and
I took me a long time to diagnose it and
I was really interested because I was
learning so much about it I didn't know
I didn't know anything about it before
and so we were kind of just kidding
around and chitchatting with this uh the
lady who was uh producing this yeah
chronic illness community may be
wondering why any of this matters here's
a clip to show you why look at this you
guys from the subreddit you guys are so
out of control this person went today I
found my boss has lupus and I laughed in
her face I had literally never heard of
it before the H3 episode and it was such
a funny bid to me when she told me she
was upset yo y all got to stop you can't
let this by the way dude this is like a
nothing post yeah two comments
from 2 hours ago it's probably has zero
likes come on this is why this video
matters don't go after my people don't
do it like this is a phenomenal stupid
out there in the real life you can't
laugh in someone's face when they tell
you have Lupus I was never telling you
guys as a joke lupus is very serious
problem you guys it's a very serious
condition frankly y'all shouldn't have
been laughing at me I might still have
Lupus it was such a fun bit to me I
doubt that the original poster was the
only one who felt this way he goes he
just went it's so funny I forgot to
laugh I love how he keeps in you saying
it's not a joke like like what I don't
get it half these clips you respond to
like right after countering what he said
it's super interesting yeah most of the
clips show me exactly and then but then
he goes no it means
this he's having a back and forth with
himself I think the problem I think the
problem with this video is that he
doesn't he's really not good at um
cherry picking right like you you're not
isolating the Great Moments you're
showing that I'm that you're wrong in
the clips you're using it's just bad
work if you're going to try to do a hit
job brother you got to do better than
that yeah you as a job application this
is horrible horrible no this is sloppy
work yeah sloppy research missing facts
oh Ashley just gave $5 and said ask
Troopers bro Ashley don't do that right
now we're doing a autism stolen
Glory someone in chat or maybe people
are asking for an Autism poll that's
actually interesting let's do that you
want that yeah uh are you on the
Spectrum let's give Jake a new material
for a new video I don't know if we
already said this but Jake do a little
research that's pretty good was a
original I think it's been said El's
calling you out well I saw Dan sent it I
don't know if it was his or he got
there's no shot guys stop it stop it
right now 50% have autism no that can't
be you guys are pulling you guys are
full of it that's ridiculous over you
guys just gave Jake a videos for years
that's what I was
saying he's GNA somehow he's going to
you your names that voted in this poll
what what's his angle if you were to use
this they got to prove it yeah they're
all F Pro scumbag they are fakers show
show me a video of you talking to
[Music]
somebody all determin there's no way 48%
of you have autism what are you guys
talking about autism chat rise the
up oh my God you guys can't be serious
right now well I mean I said a high
proportion of our audience we love we
love autis supports my conclusion are
you cannot be serious right now people
are trolling there might have been some
they're
trolling I think the population what's
the population autism I don't know
percentage it's it's like probably like
oh it's actually quite common but one
higher than that one in 36 Children s
like
2% uh more actually yeah it's like two
and a half it's a good guess that's a
lot yeah
it's not 50% though
people two and a
half well you know our audience is not
necessarily a representative of the
general public maybe we're a safe haven
for the autistic we love them we give
them we give them safe place to come and
be your true autistic self yeah I'm this
is a playground for The autistic I'm
seeing people I'm a little shy does that
count no no it doesn't no it does I
think it does yeah that might might y'
better not be self diagnosing out there
that'd be this is just an
autistic uh Utopia here on the H3
podcast we love it we should see how
many people have way all right let's
burn through this go ahead Jake dumbass
little little brain by the way I
know I got to watch the whole thing keep
on I got to watch it I got to do it
we're close there's a difference between
jokes and actual real life diseases I'm
just going to talk over him if you
aren't experiencing that disease or
symptoms yourself then maybe you
shouldn't share this quote bit with your
millions of followers especially when a
doctor never brought up the possibility
of Lupus it was all you in response to
Ethan's funny little bit I decided to
take matters into my own hands and speak
to people who had firsthand experience
with lus who are willing to tell me
their stories at the time of me
interviewing these people everybody was
down to be on camera and have their
identity share to my audience but after
reading some of the that people
have said on Reddit or my Instagram
comments I am worried for them so I'm
going to be blurring their faces and
hiding their identities yeah they didn't
say accuse anyone of Faking loopus bro
they don't this be clear nobody hates
people with lupus they hate people that
make horrible bad faith gatekeep the you
know we love the lupus we love them I
guarante the lupus yeah we love them I
guarantee you these people reached out
to him and they're like I don't want to
be in the video like this like they saw
the comments and were like take me out
and he's like okay can I blur your face
and name and then leave you in let's see
though let's see but these are 100% real
experiences prove it Li this being
released I sent an email out to the
people who were interviewed I let them
know that I was receiving threats and
people were diminishing my experiences
because I disagreed with something Ethan
said you are such a
experiences because I disagreed with
something Ethan said what a way to
phrase it yeah you made like a no CU you
made a shitty video like a fullon
personal hit job which is like the
meanest
dumbest it's just horrible I mean what
you did is just horrible nobody's made a
video this low about me ever ever on
YouTube two out of the four people that
I interviewed decided to no longer be
part of this video for their own safety
good for them for their own for their
safety oh no okay I having symptom oh
yeah I know who that
is that could be him in a wig for all we
know this is awesome man in like late
October early November of 2018 y dude
seriously this is the dumbest content
this is so stupid what the is this
oh my God after I got into a car crash
for a long time we were treating the
symptoms as if it was because of the car
crash nothing was getting better with
the treatment my symptoms were getting
worse and worse progressively did I give
these people lupus Jake what did I miss
something is the rest of this just
people talking about their their their
struggle with so let's see there's a
whole lupus moment he talks to a few
lupus folks just a bit really not even a
lot folks he just gave him a little tiny
bit of the video they did blood work and
they did I know that person you know who
that is they are not safey and they s me
to raty at that point they thought maybe
I had juvenile arthritis that's where I
got the diagn I gave
lus do a p biopsy that was not fun
because with my lupus I was having and I
was here are some other thoughts I can
understand that he's going through a lot
right now and it's scary to know that
something's wrong with you but he really
leaned head first into the lupus thing
when there was no evidence really
pointing to it it's just really
frustrating to me that he decided that
he most likely had lupus and then told
everyone before he had actually seen the
rheumatologist who told him it was not
lupus he you're such a piece of for
saying that like you dude you're
such a
liar nobody ever said at any point and
by the way what What doctor would be
like you do not have Lupus a
rheumatologist and you're showing some
symptoms AO immune no doctor would even
say that
like was it worth all the LIE definitely
not in this case it was not worth it oh
God
I just wish that he would have waited
for an actual diagnosis to talk about
things and wait for things to
R he talks about lupus like to him it's
just not that serious I get that maybe
God you don't have Lupus you don't even
have Lupus you barely have lime
disease Ethan is way more likely to have
it than you so what is being invalidated
about your lupus experience he's chronic
crew dog that's why that's oh my God you
wouldn't get it he says it's not serious
to you but it's literally so serious to
you because you've dedicated so much
time to it yes he deals with the stress
through humor that's how some people
cope off I I don't think they're
saving Jake the ligma has gone to his
brain
manma he can't he can't blame dude Lyme
disease more like lie
disease got him cuz everybody with Lyme
disease is are liars y That's a symptom
every one of those one to eight in
California those one to eight need to be
exported they need to be um sent to New
York with all the other lime idiots I
wasn't
trying oh God he's not going to get the
joke Ethan yeah I know it's going to be
tough for him it's going to be hard on
him he was really sorting through all
his emotions but from the clips that I
saw it felt like a slap in the face
here's what another you don't have Lupus
why did it feel like a slap in the face
person said you can have Lupus and
continue to test negative for it it is a
constant struggle for some of my friends
with lupus but you have to have symptoms
to even be diagnosed with or without
inflamation does not automatically equal
or any specific autoimmune disease this
whole situation this bro really thinks
he's a doctor it's incredible like for
for this guy who's gatekeeping medical
additions and advocating for people to
get proper diagnosis this man is really
sitting there giving medical diagnosises
and medical advice like I I don't think
I've ever seen anybody cosplay as a
doctor this hard who wasn't like trying
to sell me Herbal Life or some kind
of kind of idiot would cosplays
doctor yeah we hate those we hate them
no you're you're you're practically a
doctor AB don't cut yourself short thank
you thank you how many years in med
school zero well Premed Premed school
and it was seven when it was supposed to
be four right seven well if you don't
take it seriously wait wait you want to
really Gras the concepts that's what he
said earlier in the show right I didn't
you did a four-year College in seven
years were you full-time student all
seven years uh yeah I was a full-time
student but I was doing at first and
okay you Chang you switch it up yeah and
then it was not easy yeah it's not
easy it's not
[Music]
easy she made me so angry I could not
even put it into words especially oh I
made him so angry he can't put in words
lupus can we get another BL even be
diagnosed with or without a positive
test inflammation does not automatically
equal lupus or any specific autoimmune
disease this whole situation made me so
angry I could not even put words oh no
yeah what's the deal bro you don't have
a lint you lint roller happening
there's so much if you cared about this
video you would not have a hair on your
shoulder somebody said there's a lot of
stuff on the fridge too and it's about
to fall oh come on man get your fridge
in order before you getting come at my
life you've started absorbing his
hairline already it's falling off that's
what you get man you should have known
better that couch it's hot it's covered
in hair it's just like get it's
coming out that's his hair on his
shoulder I know he's I think he's
married uh which is great I love they
seem very happy and she seems very nice
and I love that about her but I think
that's his hair H okay which is
basically as he started filming this the
hair was falling out so the hair wasn't
there when he started it's interesting
only notic especially when people with
chronic illness are already fighting so
hard every single day to just exist now
people are on it another person
wrote back to me and on it the
only person on autoimmune
disease is you big time
yeah wow oh dude I hate this man he
started off by saying he doesn't know
what lupus is and then proceeded to read
every single symptom of it and say no I
don't have that which to most people I
would think would lead them to look at
other options just for fun I looked up
my numbers from when I was hospitalized
and my ANA was 1 to 1 just for fun what
he's about to big dick your dude
beat you you think you have Ana elevated
you caught a I caught a fish this
all right tell me about your Ana 280 and
another y That's crazy the test that is
more specific to lupus diagnosis is
actually the dsdna not the an I don't
want to denigrate how hard it can be to
get a diagnosis for lupus or most
autoimmune diseases because
it's that's what you've just died and
just super mean Super
personal just super wrong doesn't sit
right with me that his reason for not
being being able to get diagnosed is
that he you know what doesn't sit right
you in that couch that's right awkward
ass dumb couch dumb idiot couch
loser Square ey look at a couch that
ain't no Ikea couch dumb somebody
mentioned the pillows look really flat
fluff your pillows fluff those
pillows there's a huge scratch in the in
the back it looks like the fake
leather's cracking you could have
treated come dude treat that
yeah you don't respect your Lea
put some put some lanolin on there dude
come on get it together man yeah yeah
this doesn't sit right with me I'm going
to puke you did there El the furniture
Community is not
happy that blue on that like how you
going to have deep blue you don't have
color anywhere else in the kitchen
coward who thought you
design who's your interior designer Jake
do
little doesn't Jake do nothing but
and
moan yeah have symptoms of the I tried
you got to throw him out there and see
how they Jake yeah disease he just has a
feeling he has it I don't know it's
frustrating lastly I sent in Clips to a
medical professional with 27 years of
experience making sure to highlight all
of his tests and so you're getting me a
diagnosis from a doctor who's not my
doctor that sounds super ethical that's
got to be like a hippo that's a hippo
viation my friend what about my D Hipp
all right let's see what the doctor has
to say about this the doctor's like it's
all blurry and the doctor's like
Ethan's a he's obviously
lying he's doing it for sympathy and
money let's symptoms the doctor wrote
back to me with these thoughts lus is
definitely a difficult diagnosis and
dummy you didn't even get a
video I'm supposed to take your word for
that not one made purely on lab results
in fact the lab test results are many
times very nebulous so working with a
physician to review labs diagnos is and
course of symptoms is very important
people want a black and white lab answer
that is a yes or no but that doesn't
exist for this it also for a l ofic used
cat
GPT resp he's like oh this kid
again he he's just like I'm not I'm not
responding to him so he just cat GPT
here's a chat gbt answer that'll be
$3,000 Jake thank
you God and it's not uncommon to get a
lot of worried patients over quote
abnormal Labs that really aren't that
abnormal for example out of range
doesn't mean something bad is going on
this is different from strep test for
where the answer is Strep positive or
stre negative because lupus itself is so
variable many folks read about their
symptoms on the internet and come up
with the diagnosis when in fact they end
up not having lupus in regards to chat
GPT if I understood correctly AI
actually said it was probably not lupus
so in that case I would say the AI was
spot
on all right final words thank God so I
guess that's it I have spent 4 months
gathering information on Ethan and four
months gathering information God and
there is so much
missing well like it's just so such a
self-own to say that because every
single word thing he took he
misinterpreted took out of context gave
it the worst bad faith omitted lots of
like calling me like a classist and
then not acknowledging that I donated
money to people um you you know
according to you you know all of that
and you chose not to put it in the
video that's defamation my friend he
didn't show you doing the online quiz
right that was a that bro you want to
talk about def ansers 18 to 35
Check Yes okay I have some updated
information go ahead um from our Saudi
Prince actually um it had it had
multiple ads he said he counted 10 ads
when the video was holy also he
said it did
disclose um the information about the uh
about the merch 10% only going but it's
at the end of this video not in the
description
oh okay yeah well that's okay it doesn't
say it on the website or anything but I
mean it's something like that you need
to really disclose yeah I mean not 45
minutes in can I see can can you link me
to his merch site I call no I don't want
to go there we don't even care about
that stuff I don't care about that yeah
but okay but good you should disclose
that good I'm glad you're disclosing it
um I'd say that's a great segue into
another story but we're at four hours so
four hours welcome back team y but um 10
ads he had dud who's doing lupus
Glory right and his claims if all else
fails I hope that at least one person
after watching this video understands a
little bit more about lupus chronic
illness why it's insane to make CLS like
this and for anybody who's actively
struggling with lupus or chronic illness
who needs financial help my nonprofit
never stop will be in the description
below and you can apply there also if
you feel like it you can donate to the
neverstop fund 10% of all profits from
the clothing brand go into the fund so
either way you're helping people out
again this video had no ulterior motives
my goal was to share these claims and
how insane I thought they were and why
would you even mention alternative
motives like why would anyone even think
that in a genuine
video cuz he he CU he's a because he
knows he's a slow rat oh wow Love
Actually he was able to uh do a trace
route uh who is uh hacker phone phone
funking and um he was actually able to
find the doctor that Jake oh saled
with I know who that is can we enhance
that oh I know I went to med school with
yeah let me enhance it wait wait I'll
can we enhance that wait wait that looks
like is that that's not Jimmy Lee Love
or is it you think Jimmy it does look
like Jimmy like Jimmy dude we need to
enhance it further oh yeah these are the
here's the sunglasses right here the
hairline look at the
hairline is rocking Jimmy hairline holy
that's bad Jake that's bad I think
that's Jak do little he didn't
impersonate it wait hold on I got the
Blurred you think this is Jake it looks
like him but he wouldn't do that he
wouldn't that I just this is it un
blurred oh
yeah it it
was oh my god oh no what a liar I knew I
saw I appreciate you all so
much and uh I'll talk to you later bye
no you
want so here's my final
words let's just here's here's a video
that I'll be okay viewing on your
channel you'll have to film it on your
um your
smartphone because here's the video take
all of your
electronics your cameras your mics your
computer anything you use to make
content go to a nice spot you know that
that that is fond memories for you and
we're going to have a burial okay okay
we're going to put and remember you got
to film it on your phone cuz you can't
you're not allowed to have anything else
so put it all in there cover it up say
say some
words and
um and just wish it well you know
um you know it didn't have to be like
this you could say to them one one wrong
turn one hourong uh bad faith rant
calling someone a liar about illness to
make money
now nobody likes me I don't know nobody
likes him I
don't and then and then just say it
didn't have to be this
way someone said what the the
podcast is still
alive so if you do that then then I'll
I'll Big Ups you I'll say cool beef
squashed everybody subscribe go
subscribe to Jake do nothing Jake be
better so bury all your no you're
not that's the other thing no you're not
allowed to do that you got to bury all
your you can keep your channel open
you don't have to close it but just bury
all your and then you can post that
as your final video and I I'll big up to
it but after that you you can't do it
anymore is that a good idea or
no no all right anyway listen don't go
harass the dude it is what it is again
is what it is and it ain't what it ain't
true say were the last line of defense
for real though it's like I mean we just
spent like two and a half three hours
just eviscerating this guy nobody else
yeah he's done it's enough yeah yeah
agreed it's enough it's enough leave him
alone but like again this dude had it up
all month and literally said I will do
anything to make this stop he's posted
this yesterday the video was up on his
all of his it's like bro what what
do you expect me the messiest in
the world to do when you someone accused
me of lying about faking an illness to
make money give me a break I will do
anything to make this stop when nobody
said anything nobody said
make I don't actually that's true cuz I
don't think he posted a video or a post
so I don't
know it's totally just he's punching me
don't hit me
back anyway I think hopefully you have a
bright future
and maybe you talk to animals maybe be a
veterinarian talk to animals dude what
if he was a vet and his real name is Dr
doitt would be awesome is great you born
for this Jake you were born for that
yeah please make it happen that'd be so
cool and don't shame dogs if they come
with some weird blood work don't call
them a
okay all right listen thanks everybody
we're
back we're back baby and thank you
members go up for 250 gifted memberships
right at the tail end of the show there
see being gold out in the chat right now
250 250 of them is that for lupus or not
is that for the lupus or the show we
need to yeah we need to make a clear
separation for accounting purposes we
put all the lupus donations in one one
place I have a charity where 10 where 1%
of it goes to lupus I'm putting it all
there so your help it's all it's all for
good um
that's so nice thank you so much uh Subs
go up we love you we really do and thank
you to everybody who donated and um
gifted membership that means a lot thank
you to our members thank you to
everybody for coming and tuning in mhm
appreciate it nice to be back and we'll
be back again on Wednesday for another
action-packed episode of the a Street
podcast until then everybody
t
[Music]